bonjour à tous hier soir les sénateurs
ont entamé l'examen des articles du
projet de loi sur la consommation examen
en deuxème lecture de ce texte présenté
par le ministre à l'économie sociale et
solidaire Benoît amont ce texte vise
essentiellement à rétablir le lien de
confiance entre les consommateurs et les
entreprises c'est l'une des clés du
retour à la croissance selon le
gouvernement ce texte vise également à
mieux informer et mieux défendre les
consommateurs hier parmi les points
abordés on peut mentionner notamment la
question de l'action de groupe puisque
ce texte met en place l'action de groupe
à la française une action qui devra
nécessairement passer par l'une des 16
associations agréées de Défense des
Consommateurs action de groupe dont
exclus du champ également et bien les
questions de l'environnement ou encore
de la santé tout de suite retour donc à
l'examen de ce t texte qui s'est déroulé
hier soir au
Sénat monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission messieurs les
rapporteurs madame la rapporteur pour
avis nous reprenons la discussion du
projet de loi adopté en 2uxè lecture par
l'Assemblée nationale relatif à la
consommation la discussion a été close
avant la suspension nous sommes parvenus
à la discussion des articles j'ai une
demande de parole de Madame Bonnefoi au
titre de la commission des lois madame
Bonnefoi vous avez la parle
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon
intervention se limitera à préciser la
raison d'être des trois amendements que
la commission des lois a déposé en vue
de cette seconde lecture à ce stade de
nos travaux est contenu des votes
intervenus et des progrès enregistrés
seul l'article 1er parmi tous ceux que
nous avions examiné en première lecture
nous a paru justifier le dépôt de
nouveaux amendements ceci vise à
rétablir des dispositions adoptées par
le Sénat en première lecture mais que
l'assemblée a supprimé un fil conducteur
relit ces trois amendements il s'agit à
chaque fois de rétablir une garantie
protectrice des intérêts des
consommateurs ou de ceux des du
professionnel la première garantie est
celle qu'une action de groupe ne
prospère pas sur des préjudices fictifs
ou potentiels mais qu'elle soit conduite
à partir de situations réelles et de cas
individuel déterminé la seconde garantie
est que les fonds qui transitent par
l'association
soit protégé et que les consommateurs
lésés ne risquent pas de perdre leur
indemnisation en raison du défaut de
l'association qui les aura reçu enfin la
dernière garantie est que les
consommateurs lésés puissent
effectivement participer à l'action de
groupe et qu'il dispose d'un recours si
l'association refusait de recevoir leur
adhésion au groupe ou de transmettre
leur demande d'indamnisation si la
procédure d'action de groupe repose sur
l'idée que l'association joue le rôle
d'un filtre entre l'ensemble des
consommateur et le professionnel et s'il
est important qu'elle ne se dissolve pas
en une multitude d'actions individuelles
il est tout aussi essentiel que les
intéressés soient assurés de pouvoir
participer à une action qui les concerne
or la seule façon de le garantir et de
leur reconnaître un droit à un recours
effectif contre la décision qui s'y
opposerait le succès de l'action de
groupe procédure innovante et au combien
nécessaire ne sera complet qu'à deux
conditions en premier lieu il faut que
la procédure soit lisible claire afin
que chacun puisse la comprendre et se
l'approprier en second lieu il faut
qu'elle présente suffisamment de
garanties pour les consommateurs pour
les professionnels et pour les
associations afin que nul ne conteste sa
légitimité et que chacun puisse s'y
soumettre en confiance voilà c'est le
sens des trois amendements que j'ai
déposé que je présenterai au nom de la
commission des lois merci Madame la
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des lois donc nous entamons l'examen des
amendements un exam un amendement numéro
33 est présenté par Monsieur
mzard monsieur mzard vous présentez
l'amendement merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'article 1er de ce projet de
loi créer une procédure d'action de
groupe dans les domaines du droit de la
consommation et de la concurrence notre
amendement propose une nouvelle
rédaction de cet article qui est
d'ailleurs inspirée d'une proposition de
loi qu' a déposé notre collègue plan
cade qui va plus loin que le dispositif
de l'article 1er en proposant un
dispositif d'action de groupe alternatif
à la fois simple et efficace qui
pourrait s'appliquer à différents
domaines à commencer par ceux de la
consommation de la concurrence et de la
santé l'action de groupe que nous
proposons par cet amendement couvrirait
la réparation des dommages individuel de
toute nature ainsi que l'ensemble du
contentieux de la responsabilité civile
en effet circonscrire l'action de groupe
à la réparation de dommage matériel
trouvant leur origine dans un manquement
contractuel ou précontractuel
ou un manquement aux règles de la
concurrence comme le propose l'article
1er aurait un intérêt plus limité pour
les consommateur autre différence
importante avec le dispositif de
l'article 1er cet amendement propose un
agrément spécifique des associations
autorisées à exercer des actions de
groupe et nous proposons aussi un
dispositif qui nous semble tout à fait
crédible et applicable pour
l'application de l'action de groupe au
produits de santé qui est un domaine où
un tel type de recours est
particulièrement
nécessaire merci Monsieur mard je vais
donc demander l'avis de la commission
sur cet amendement numéro
33 l'amendement de notre collègue
Plancade a déjà été déposé en première
lecture par le
Sénat euh je ne je ne reviens pas sur la
présentation qui était faite de
l'amendement simplement la commission
des affaires économiques soutient le
choix fait par le gouvernement de
limiter le champ de l'action de groupe
au champ de la consommation et de la
concurrence le dispositif du présent
projet de loi ne prévoit pas la
réparation que les seuls préjudices
matériels en matière de santé et
d'environnement les préjudices sont
également potentiellement physiques et
moraux leur évaluation ne peut-être
qu'individuelle euh dans ce cas la
procédure prévue par l'article 1er euh
n'est pas du tout euh adapté euh
l'article de Monsieur Plancade alors
enfin le gouvernement a annoncé c'est
surtout ça la réponse que je ferai lors
des débats à l'Assemblée nationale
qu'une action de groupe serait proposée
dans un prochain texte sur la santé la
ministre de la Santé l'a annoncé et
qu'une réflexion serait lancée sur la
mise en place d'une action de groupe en
matière d'environnement je pense que
monsieur le ministre pourra nous
confirmer euh cette orientation et il me
semble préférable de ne pas précipiter
les choses sur le sujet et je demanderai
le retrait de cet amendement sinon ce
serait défavorable merci monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre bon sans surprise
l'avis du Gouvernement est semblable à
l'avis du
rapporteur il y a une logique à la fois
élargir le champ de l'action de groupe
tel que le propose le groupe radical il
a proposé en même temps que toute
association
puisse être légitime à ouvrir une une
procédure de la sorte n nous avons voulu
limiter l'action de groupe pas la
limiter en tout cas faire en sorte que
l'action de groupe dans le champ
économique concerne les litiges de
consommation et les litige de
concurrence ce qui justifie que seuls
les associations de consommateurs soient
habilité à les porter il y a plusieurs
types d'action de groupe qui peuvent
parfaitement coexister c'est ainsi que
le gouvernement va procéder puisque
quand il s'agira de s'attaquer aux
actions de groupe dans le champ de la
santé qui suppose outre que l'on
détermine le niveau du préjudice il
faudra évaluer ce qui'est le préjudice
individuel subi par chaque personne
victime de l'absorption par exemple
d'une mauvaise molécule et que cette
expertise individuelle suppose une
procédure différente de celle dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui puisque dans le
champ de l'action de groupe il s'agit
d'un litige ou d'un préjudice semblable
qui appelle une réparation semblable
sauf dans les cas où nous avons 2 ans
d'abonnement à journal contre un an
d'abonnement ave que le préjudice et sur
2 ans pour certains et sur un an pour
d'autres mais en tout cas euh c'est
c'est là la différence raison pour
laquelle je confirme bien que le
gouvernement a l'intention 2è étage de
la fusée de proposer une action de
groupe dans le champ de la santé Marie
soltouren l'a annoncé et que nous avons
ouvert euh euh dans lors des états
généraux du droit d'environnement la
question du débat sur l'action de groupe
dans le champ de l'environnement
confirmé lors de la dernière conférence
environnementale c'est donc une fusée à
trois étages et il s'agissait pour nous
de monter en puissance progressivement
et de mettre en œuvre tout de suite sans
délai et ce sera le cas dès cette année
si vous l'adoptez et bien l'action de
groupe dans le champ de la consommation
et de la concurrence c'est pourquoi
Monsieur le Président mesard je vous
demanderai où de retirer oou en tout cas
le gouvernement donnera un avis
défavorable à votre amendement merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur mard vous
êtes sollicité par deux demandes de
retrait que
décidez-vous vous voulez retirer
merci je suis saisie de 14 amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion
commune le premer le numéro 34 vous le
défendez monsieur
Mor
défendre madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement est aussi inspiré de la
proposition de loi portant création
d'une action de groupe en matière de
consommation de concurrence et de santé
que nous avons déposé le 5 avril 2013
avec une proposition de définition
générale de la action de groupe visant à
faire reconnaître la responsabilité
civile d'une personne agissant en tant
que professionnelle producteur vendeur
prestataire de service à l'égard d'un
groupe de personnes physiques acheteurs
consommateurs usagers qui ont subi de
son fait des préjudices individuels
ayant une origine commune il s'agit de
fait d'une définition beaucoup plus
large que celle actuellement prévue par
l'article 1er de ce projet de loi tout
d'abord elle inclut tous les types de
dommages individuels et pas seulement
les dommages matériels ensuite elle
couvre l'ensemble du contentieux de la
responsabilité civile qu'elle soit
contractuelle délictuelle ou du fait des
produits défectueux et cet amendement
propose donc en outre une double
habilitation pour les associations de
consommateurs autoriser à exercer des
actions de groupe afin d'éviter toute
dériv et de sécuriser au maximum le
dispositif merci Monsieur mard
l'amendement 134 rectifié défendu par
Madame Lamur merci Madame la président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à s'assurer que la
procédure d'optine est respectée tout au
long de la procédure d'action de groupe
l'association de défense des
consommateurs ne serait en effet de sa
propre initiative soumettre des cas aux
juges sans que les consommateurs
concernés en effet la demande expresse
c'est pourquoi l'association doit être
dûement saisie par les consommateurs
c'est l'objet de
l'amendement merci Madame Lamur j'en
viens à l'amendement 35 monsieur
mzard merci madame la Présidente donc
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
dans la ligne de l'amendement précédent
nous proposons que les associations de
consommateurs autorisés à exercer des
actions de groupe fassent l'objet d'une
habilitation spéciale qui s'ajouterit à
l'agrément des associations de
consommateurs représentatives au niveau
national prévu à l'article l4111 du Code
de la Consommation cela pour permettre à
la fois de rendre le dispositif vraiment
effectif et sûr en habilitant les seules
associations capables et légitimes pour
porter des actions de groupe au nom des
consommateurs merci Monsieur mzard le
199 crtifié n'est pas défendu il tombe
le 244 madame ai c'est un amendement
identique vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous le savez je suis avec ma collègue
Chantal joanau et l'ensemble du groupe
écologiste particulièrement attaché une
conception ambitieuse de l'action de
groupe c'est pourquoi nous avons euh
souhaité redéposer sur ce texte certains
amendements déjà défendus en première
lecture en l'occurrence le présent
amendement s'inscrit dans une logique
d'élargissement de l'action de groupe
son but est d'étendre la procédure à
d'autres juridictions et de permettre
notamment aux citoyens lésés de lancer
une action de groupe contre une personne
morale de droit public en effet pour que
l'action de groupe soit un réel progrès
qui profite véritablement au citoyens il
faut que ces derniers puissent y
recourir dans tout type de situations or
des citoyens peuvent parfois se trouver
lesésés du fait de certaines décisions
publiques prenons le cas d'une commune
qui n'aurait pas respecté les règles de
mise en concurrence dans l'attribution
d'un marché public les citoyens léésé
par le coût anormalement élevé d'un
service public se trouve ainsi victime
d'un même préjudice dans ce type de
situation l'action de groupe peut-être
une réponse à ce groupe de citoyens par
cette disposition il s'agit donc de
créer un nouvel outil ou réduire les
déséquilibres entre les pouvoirs publics
et les citoyens pour rester en cohérence
avec l'article 121-2 du code pénal
relatif la responsabilité pénale des
personnes cette extension ne concerne
que les personnes publiques autre que
l'État à savoir les régions départements
communes et établissements publics je
vous remercie merci Madame ai le 180 et
Monsieur
Doliger monsieur le ministre chers
collègues je vais présenter quelques
amendements cours de cette soirée euh
l'objectif sera toujours le même hein
c'est d'essayer de de simplifier de
clarifier je vous rappelle qu'on doit
être en principe dans le choc de
simplification et j'ai pas le sentiment
que de texte ce texte nouveau va
beaucoup amener dans la simplification
dans notre société et et et moi je pense
que l'important c'est l'entreprise et
que ça c'est un texte d'avant le 14
janvier c'est pas un ciel un texte
social démocrate pour moi c'est un texte
qui n'aurait peut-être pas existé après
le 14 après le 14 janvier écouter le
discours qui a été prononcé le le 14
janvier euh
ouis non
mais je je crois que
je crois que c'est quand même important
de de vous le rappeler surtout en cette
période où vous avez tout à l'heure il a
été rappelé un certain nombre de choses
par nos amis CRC sur le PACT moi je
rappellerai quand même qu'il y avait eu
un engagement très fort sur la courbe du
chômage on en a pas encore parlé ce soir
mais que les entreprises c'est quand
même l'élément essentiel actuellement
c'est d'essayer de développer l'emploi
et je ne suis pas certain que l'analyse
de ce texte aille dans ce sens toujours
est-il qu'on va essayer quand même d'y
apporter quelques simplifications et
objectif du texte c'est de remplacer
enfin de l'amendement subi par des
consommateurs par un groupe significatif
et identifiable de consommateur pourquoi
pourquoi cela parce que nous pensons que
l'action de groupe est une procédure qui
se justifie uniquement dans les cas ne
pouvont pas être traités de manière
efficace selon les procédures de droit
commun cela a été dit tout à l'heure il
existe des procédures de droit commun
quelques quelques consommateurs
seulement deux ou trois ne peuvent
suffire à constituer un groupe le groupe
initiale de consommateurs concernés par
l'action de groupe doit avoir une
consistance suffisante en étant d'une
taille significative en ce sens la
recommandation de la Commission
européenne de juin 2013 et il me semble
toujours intéressant de se référer à la
Commission européenne pour un certain
nombre de raisons c'est que nous avons
toujours tendance à en rajouter par
rapport à la règle européenne et bien la
Commission européenne relative à des
principes commun applicable au
mécanismes de recours collectif en
cessation et en réparation dans les
États-membres viv précisément les
préjudices de masse impliquant par
définition des groupes significatifs par
ailleurs les membres de ce groupe
doivent être concernés par un même
préjudice celui pour lequel il mandate
l'association afin d'ester en justice
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
déposé cet amendement et je sais que
dans votre esprit qui devient assez
libéral vous suivrez la proposition que
je vous fais merci Monsieur Doliger le
296 rectifié n'est pas défendu il tombe
le 135 rectifié madame Lamur monsieur
Cornu madame
oui madame la Présidente alors nous
estimons que l'action de groupe est
justifiée dans les situations où les
consommateurs constituant le groupe se
trouve dans une situation identique dès
lors qu'ils sont dans une situation
uniquement similaire l'évaluation de la
situation individuelle de chaque
consommateur devient nécessaire pour
s'assurer de la consistance du groupe et
dans ce cadre les procédures de droit
commun plus adapté doivent être
privilégiées merci chers collègues le
182 monsieur
doliget
pas madame la Présidente et monieur le
ministre chers collègues le préambule
j'ai fait mais ça serait le même
exactement donc l'état d'esprit même
donc c'est de rédiger d'apporter C
alinéas supplémentaires qui vise à
préciser les conditions de recevabilité
de l'action de groupe dans le but de
s'assurer du sérieux des actions
intentées par des associations et
d'éviter les procédures abusives ou
mener à des fins de
déstabilisation tout d'abord l'action de
groupe doit rester une procédure
d'exception c'est pour cela qu'il faut
s'assurer que les procédures de droit
commun ne sont pas adaptées à traiter le
litige les droits étrangers qui
connaissent des procédures d'action de
groupe prévoi ainsi généralement dans
leurs conditions de recevabilité que
l'action n'est recevable que si elle est
démontrer que l'on ne peut agir par une
autre voie il s'agit également de
s'assurer que l'association dispose des
ressources et assurances nécessaires
pour mener l'action jusqu'à son terme il
me semble que dans un certain nombre de
textes sur la simplification il est il
est prévu que l'on ne puisse pas faire
des recours excessifs en permanence il
faut donc pour cela se garantir d'un
certain nombre de protection et
l'objectif bien sûr c'est de se garantir
contre l'exagération dans un certain
nombre d'actions enfin dans la logique
de l'optin l'association de
consommateurs doit disposer d'un mandat
express de la part des consommateurs
dont le cas est soumis au Tribunal on
peut imaginer par exemple un mandat
simplifié par voie
électronique merci chers collègues le
136 madame la M
oui madame la Présidente et bien fidèle
à la logique de l'optine nous insistons
pour dire que l'association de
consommateurs doit disposer d'un mandat
express de la part des consommateurs
dans le cas est soumis au Tribunal mer
chers collègues le 196 rectifié de
Madame Joan n'est pas défendu il tombe
mais madame ai le même je vous invite à
le
présenter merci madame le Président mes
chers collègue cet amendement vise à
élargir la portée de l'action de groupe
en l'ouvrant à de nouveaux préjudices et
notamment ceux en matière
d'environnement et de santé en effet
restreindre l'action de groupe à la
rédaction du seul préjudice matériel a
pour conséquence de limiter l'impact du
dispositif et d'exclure de nombreux
citoyens laésés de la possibilité
d'obtenir réparation les privant ainsi
d'une réponse adaptée en matière de
scandale sanitaire notamment pensons au
victimes des protestes PIP a priori les
multiples consommatrices victimes d'un
même dommage auraient intérêt à lancer
une action de groupe pourtant l'état une
action de groupe ne permettrait de
rembourser que les prothèses et en aucun
cas les dommages corporels dans de
nombreux secteurs économiques cet
élargissement de l'action de groupe à la
santé et l'environnement fait peur chez
les entreprises dont l'activité génère
des nuisances sanitaires et
environnementales cette crainte est
justifiée la procédure d'action de
groupe étendu à la santé et à
l'environnement permettrait en effet aux
citoyens de dénoncer les violations du
principe de précaution qui leurit qui
leur aurait porté préjudice les
entreprises responsables devraient alors
légitimement assumer les dommages
qu'elles ont ont causé cette crainte sur
le court terme n'est pas justifiée à
long terme en effet l'action de groupe
ne visant pas à se fixer un secteur
économique mais à dénoncer les pratiques
bafouant le principe de précaution elle
permettrait simplement de mieux réguler
un secteur à long terme en incitant les
entreprises à prendre en compte les
enjeux de santé publique plus en amont
l'action de groupe enfin en matière de
santé environnement se rapproche
finalement du travail des lanceurs
d'Alert c'est un dispositif constructif
qui permet aux citoyens d'aider les
acteurs économiques à améliorer la
qualité de leur offre et finalement de
gagner en en compétitivité merci merci
chers collègues le 183 monsieur Doliger
c'est le dernier amendement de la série
vous le
présentez ce plaisir madame la
Présidente donc je vais prendre que
l'amendement je vais pas prendre de
préambule euh donc pour rappeler
simplement que dans cet amendement
l'objectif c'est de mettre un seuil
au-delà duquel l'action de groupe ne
serait pas pas possible donc l'objectif
est de réserver les actions de groupe à
la réparation des petits litiges
conformément au terme de l'étude
d'impact puisqu'il y a donc eu une étude
que je pense vous avez tous lu qui
précise qu' égard à la faiblesse des
montants sur lesquels portent ces
litiges les consommateurs renoncent
souvent à toute action individuelle sur
le terrain judiciaire autrement dit
l'action de groupe porte en réalité sur
les sommes modestes qui prises
individuellement ne sont pas en pratique
réclamés par le consommateur car le
présente une un ratio coût de procédure
avant age dissuasif par ailleurs comme
le soulligne l'étude d'impact qui
indique qu'aucune étude destinée à
évaluer l'impact sur l'économie des
actions de groupe n'a été mené il
convient d'encadrer le montant des
préjudices indemnisables afin d'en
limiter les risques économiques sur les
entreprises en effet à défaut de
plafonnement les entreprises notamment
les PME TPE et artisans je pense que
c'est des catégories qui nous intéresse
ne seront pas en mesure de faire face au
coût d'une assurance reflétant un tel
risque je rappelle aussi que dans le
cadre du texte il y a des dispositions
sur les assurances qui risquent
d'augmenter les taux d'assurance qui
bien sûr pénaliseraiit encore plus les
PME et artisans elles seront alors
contraintes de s'assurer avec des
plafonds de garantie insuffisants au
regard du risque encouru en tout état de
cause les entreprises exposées ainsi sur
leur patrimoine propre verront leur
risque de défaillance accru voilà madame
la Présidente merci chers collègues je
vais donc demander à notre rapporteur
lepp rorteur de la commission des
affaires économiques de nous donner
l'avis des l'avis de la commission sur
les amendements restants en
discussion sur l'amendement
34 cet amendement qui a été déjà rejeté
par le Sénat en première lecture qui
vise l'extension de l'action de groupe à
la réparation des dommages individuels
de toute nature et à l'ensemble du
contentieux de la responsabilité civile
il remet comme c'était dit en première
lecture l'équilibre du dispositif
proposé
euh qui s'inspire il faut le dire hein
c'est important de le dire assez
largement de la vie du Conseil national
de la consommation du 4 décembre 2012 je
le rappelle le Conseil national de la
consommation est une instance comprenant
des représentants des consommateurs et
des représentants des professionnels il
paraît souhaitable à la Commission d'
rester à la réparation des préjudices
matériels trouvant leur origine dans un
manque contractuel ou précontractuel
l'extension à d'autres préjudices moraux
pourrait ouvrir la voie à des excès pour
ce qui concerne les associations la
Commission estime que le filtre
introduit par le projet de loi des 16
associations de consommateurs seront en
mesure d'engager une action de groupe et
il ne paraî pas utile de créer une
habilitation sorte de super agrément
permettant d'engager une action de
groupe vous demanderez le le retrait euh
ou ça serait un avis
défavorable concernant l'amendement 134
rectifié là aussi il
s'agit en gros il est demandé au
consommateurs de manifester leur volonté
explicite de participer à l'action de
groupe le principe de l'optout n'est en
effet pas conforme à la Constitution
comme l'a indiqué la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel du 25 juillet 89 et donc
un avis aussi euh défavorable sur cette
question euh ilut parce que cet
amendement visait à préciser que
l'association de défense des
consommateur qui engage une action de
coûte doit être dûement
saisie sur le
35 35 qui est aussi déposé rejeté en
première lecture
euh il semble bien que le filt proposé
par la loi paraît largement suffisant
euh et pourquoi limiter l'action de
groupe à à certaines de ces 16
associations
retrait sinon défavorable l'article
199 identique au 244 et aussi qui avait
été déposé rejeté par le Sénat en
première lecture c'est des amendements
190 et
244 sur la deuxème partie de
l'amendement la Commission s'est montrée
très sceptique on a du mal à voir dans
quelle mesure les régions les
départements ou les communes pourrai
être responsable d'un manquement à
loocation à l'occasion de la vente d'un
bien ou des fournitures des services
quoi qu'il en soit le texte du projet de
loi ne fait pas de distinction entre les
personnes physiques ou personnes morales
quel que soit le droit privé ou le droit
public là aussi défavorable ou aux
amendements 199
244 l'article de Monsieur Doliger
identique au 296 un petit commentaire
pour notre collègue de l'IG il n'y a pas
l'avant et l'après il y a un projet de
loi qui est équilibrée qui fait en sorte
que les consommateurs soient mieux
défendus depuis 30 ans on voulait ce
projet de loi Jacques Chirac en avait
parlé monsieur Sarkozi en avait parlé et
il est fait il est mise en place par le
gouvernement et le
souci du ministre mais aussi le souci du
Sénat comme de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est d'avoir un projet de loi équilibré
qui qui permettent à la fois de défendre
les consommateurs mais qui permettent
aussi de garantir que les entreprises
pourront travailler dans de bonnes
conditions et l'idée c'est pas le toute
entreprise ou le tout consommateur et le
filtre des 16 associations est là pour
garantir cette sécurité donc il est
proposé dans dans cette dans cet
amendement que la notion de groupe
significatif et
identifiable est une sont des notions
assez floues le filtre des associ tion
de consommateurs paraît largement
suffisant donc un avis défavorable aux
amendements 180 et
296 l'amendement 135 rectifié qui vise à
limiter la réparation des préjudices
subis par des consommateurs placés dans
une situation identique cet amendement
réduirait considérablement l'intérêt de
la procédure de l'action de groupe la
Commission ne peut être que défavorable
à cet amendement avis
défavorable monsieur dolig qui a
présenté l'article
182 un amendement qui avait été aussi
déposé rejeté par le Sénat en première
lecture les deux amendements mentionnent
une condition qui est totalement
satisfaite par le projet de loi actuel à
savoir l'acceptation expresse des
consommateurs dans le cas est soumis au
tribunal par l'association des
consommateurs le dispositif de l'optout
étant pas conforme au principe
constitutionnel de notre pays cette
condition est satisfaite
autre difficulté posée par les
amendements c'est il laisse à penser que
la recevabilité de l'action n'est
contionné que par les conditions
figurant dans ces amendements or il est
indispensable que d'autres conditions de
recevabilité soit réuni tel que
l'agrément de l'association est un
argument majeur la similarité ou
l'identité des situations des
consommateurs le caractère matériel des
préjudices dans ces conditions la
commission est défavorable à ces
amendements amendement 136 sur l'article
1er même argumentaire que l'amendement
182 un avis défavorable amendement 196
rectifié identique au 245 c'est une
question aussi évoquée en première
lecture l'action de groupe ne doit pas
être limitée à la réparation des
préjudices matériels comme je l'ai dit
précédemment dans le défense de la
position de la commission euh il ne faut
pas élargir la l'action de groupe à
d'autres à d'autres secteurs comme la
santé ou l'environnement ça se fera
ultérieurement dans des conditions
précises et prévues par la loi avis
défavorable le l'amendement euh 1emer
proche du 183 limitation de l'action de
groupe au préjudice d'un montant
inférieur au seuil fixé par
décret l'amendement déposé et rejeté par
le Sénat en première lecture l'action de
groupe ne peut-être envisagé que pour
obtenir réparation de préjudice d'un
montant inférieur à un seuil fixé par
décret c'est ce que propose notre
collègue d'olig je je comprends
bien l'intention de nos collègues il est
évident que la procédure de l'action de
groupe a pour a pour intérêt de répondre
à la situation actuelle où les
consommateurs renoncent à une action
individuelle du faible du fait du faible
montant des petits litiges de la
consommation pour autant la commission
n'est pas favorable à cet amendement
pourquoi fixer un plafond pour le
montant des préjudice et quelle en
serait la justification avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement sur cette série
d'amendements alors je vais essayer de
de de dire en style télégraphique parce
que tous ces amendements ont été
discutés en première lecture et avait
reçu un avis défavorable du gouvernement
je commencerai par les 34 et 3 5 du du
groupe RDSE pour dire que conformément à
la position sur l'article 33 et et et le
champ d'application je je donnerai un
avis défavorable au fait qu'on étende au
préjudice au dommages corporel et moraux
et sur la question du double agrément
faut savoir aujourd'hui que les
association de consommateurs début de
l'année 2013 il y en avait 17 début de
l'année 2014 il n en a plus que 15
l'agrément qu'elle reçoivent est un
agrément exigeant qui vérifie les leur
représentativité sur le territoire la
réalité des prestations à l'end drroit
des consommateurs qu'elle délivre et
ensuite qu'elle propose toutes les
garanties de de d'honnêteté et
d'intégrité ce qui fait qu' à nos yeux
c'est un agrément qui est largement
suffisant c'est la raison pour laquelle
je demanderai sur ces deux amendements
ou le retrait ou un avis défavorable du
gouvernement sur les les amendements qui
ont été déposés par Madame Lamur et
Monsieur César monsieur Doliger le
groupe UMP je suis assez surpris de de
la remarque qui nous est faite sur le
choc de simplification parce que si je
prends les amendements les uns après les
autres mettre en place un groupe dûement
saisi en lieu et place aujourd'hui du
fait que nous avons une procédure qui va
être saisie de cas individuels dûement
saisi ça complexifie considérablement la
procédure monsieur Doliger nous propose
ensuite de mettre en place un groupe
significatif et identifiable qu'est-ce
qu'un groupe significatif qu'est-ce
qu'un groupe identifiable au regard des
différentes mesures là encore nous
allons faire un choc de complexification
j'observe que vous voulez pas que soit
pr en vous voulez que ne soit pr en
cause par que les les les les cas
identiques et pas semblabl pourquoi
semblable dans le cas où un organe de
presse aurait vous ferez subir un
préjudice pour un abonnement pour ce
journal pour 2 ans pour certains pour 1
an faut mieux que ce soit semblable et
pas identique parce que le préjudice
n'est pas semblable n'est pas identique
quand on a un abonnement de 2 ans et un
abonnement de 1 an c'est pour ça que
nous avons mis semblable là encore il y
a une volonté d'être plus simple
monsieur Doliger nous propose rien de
moins que CIN alinéas supplémentaires
pour juger de la recevabilité de de de
l'action groupe à l'article 182 cela me
paraître en choc de complexification
supplémentaire ce que propose également
madame Lamur à l'article 136 et de sur
croix à l'article à l'amendement pardon
183 monsieur Doliger nous propose de
mettre en place un seuil seuil lequel
pourquoi à partir de de de quel niveau
pardon de vous dire mais ce que je
comprends de vos amendements c'est que
vous voulez une mini action de groupe ou
une action de mini groupe une action de
groupe minus mais en tout cas c'est
clairement que vous cherchez à porter à
réduire considérablement la la portée de
l'action de groupe moi je ne veux pas
d'une action de groupe minus je ne veux
pas d'une mini action de groupe ou d'une
action de mini groupe je veux d'une
action de groupe qui permettent au
consommateurs d'être indemnisé
réellement il y en a un peu marre de ces
tigres de papier dont on nous annonce
qu'ils vont rugir et défendre les
consommateurs en l'occurrence moi je
veux que demain le consommateur soit
véritablement en capacité de défendre
ses intérêts et l'action de groupe que
nous lui proposons nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui et de nature à répondre cela
à cela et et je regrette que vous
rajoutiez de la complexité à travers
toutes ces dispositions supplémentaires
là où nous recherchons au contraire la
simplicité le fait est que nous sommes
aussi obligés de donner et Madame Aichi
le sait bien un avis défavorable à à à
l'extension à l'environnement et la
santé pour les raisons que j'ai donné
dans ma réponse à Monsieur mzard tout à
l'heure mais si vous je dois vous le
répéter l'engagement est pris par le
gouvernement dans le champ de la santé
le débat est ouvert confirmé par
Philippe Martin après Delphine bateau
dans le champ de l'environnement et
répété lors de la conférence
environnementale il y a la volonté du
gouvernement d'avancer sur ce débat euh
c'est euh je vous avez aussi posé une un
amendement madame euh Aichi le 244 sur
les SPIC or les SPIC euh les services
publics industriels et commerciaux sont
concernés par l'action de groupe dès
lors qu'il n'y ait une relation
contractuel et un contrat de
consommation donc ils ne sont pas exclus
du champ donc je veux vous le confirmer
à nouveau ici raison pour laquelle à mes
yeux le 244 est déjà couvert par la
rédaction actuelle du projet de loi euh
je vous demanderis donc le retrait sur
cet amendement et sur celui sur
l'environnement et la santé sauf dans le
cas contraire nous donnerons un avis
défavorable merci Monsieur le le
ministre je vais donc mettre au voix
l'amendement 34 s'il n'y a pas de
demande d'explication de vote deux avis
défavorables ou une demande de retrait
le groupe
RDSE bon Monsieur M donc je je le mets
au voix je le met au voix deux avis
défavorables C deux demandes de retrait
donc deux avis défavorables qui est pour
c'est l'amendement de monsieur
mzard qui est
pour qui est
contre merci abstention il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 134 rectifié de
Madame Namur deux avis défavorables qui
est
pour merci qui est
contre merci chers cègues
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 35
présenté par Monsieur
mard demande de retrait de avis
défavorabl qui est pour qui est
contre merci abstention il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement de Madame ai le 244
une demande de
retrait vous le maintenez je le mets au
voie deux avis défavorables qui est
pour merci
contre merci chers collègu abstention il
n pas adopté l'amendement 180 présenté
par notre collègue d'oliger deux avis
défavorables qui est
pour merci qui est
contre merci chers collègues abstention
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 135
rectifié présenté par Madame Lamur qui
est
pour merci qui est
contre merci chers collègues abstention
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 10 82
monsieur Doliger qui est satisfait pour
la Commission à l'avis défavorable de
monsieur le ministre qui est
pour merci
contre merci chers collègues abstention
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement de
Madame Namur Lamur 136 qui est
pour merci qui est contre merci chers
collègu abstention il n'est pas adopté
madame Aichi le 245 vous le maintenez
également qui est pour merci qui est
contre contre merci abstention il n'est
pas adopté le 90 n'est pas le dernier le
183 de Monsieur Doliger vous voulez vous
expliquer je vous en prie Monsieur
doliget rapide parce que j'ai pas voulu
reprendre la parole sur tous les
amendements bon bien sûr c'était facile
pour Monsieur le Ministre de dire il y a
quelques paragraphes de plus donc ça
complexifie je pense que de mettre des
règles simple ça permet après de
simplifier les choses parce que vous
vous êtes dans l'arbitraire on fait ce
qu'on veut il y a pas de règles et puis
sont les uns ou les autres qui
décideront moi je mettais quelques
règles et en plus vous remarquerez que
en général je faisais rappel à des
règlements européens et que les
règlements européens en général c'est
plus simple que de rajouter des règles
françaises sur des règles européennes
mais bon toute façon comme la loi
passera on jugera monsieur le ministre
donc c'était simplement pour vous donner
quelques indications qui m'aurait qui
auraient certainement permis d'améliorer
votre texte c'est tout merci Monsieur
doliget monsieur le
ministre il y a juste un mot que je peux
pas laisser passer c'est arbitraire
parce que l'arbitraire sous le contrôle
du juge ça n'existe pas je ne crois pas
et en l'occurrence c'est le juge qui
jugera et ensuite la démocratie qui
tranchera mais pour l'action de groupe
c'est le juge qui jugera merci monsieur
le ministre je mets au voix donc
l'amendement présenté par notre collègue
d'IG deux avis défavorables qui est pour
merci chers collègu qui est contre merci
abstention il n'est pas
adopté nous arrivons à deux amendements
quiist l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur tandonné vous présentez le 197
rectifié
bis vise à supprimer le monopole des
associations représentatives et agréées
pour engager une action de groupe j'ai
compris qu'il y aurait 16 associations
cette restriction limite en effet de
manière trop drastique l'accès de tous
de tous les justiciables à la procédure
d'action de groupe alors que dans ce
cadre la référence à un groupe de
consommateur est primordial donc c'est
un amendement de simplification qui
introduit la possibilité pour les
consommateurs d'agir directement en
justice dès lors qu'ils sont regroupés
et en nombre suffisant fixés à 50 et
concernés bien sûr par le même préjudice
l'avocat qu'ils auront choisi pourra
ainsi conduire la procédure c'est donc
vraiment simple et ça reprend les
principes de liberté et d'égalité que
nous partageons tous ici je vous
remercie chers collègues le 243 rectifié
qui est identique madamei vous le
présentez vous considérez qu'il est
défendu peut-être il est défendu je vous
remercie donc je demander l'avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
identiques la suppression du monopole
des associations de consommateurs pour
engager une action de
groupe une
possibilité demander pour les
groupements de consommateurs d'engager
cette
action ces amendements ont été déposés
mais aussi rejetés par le Sénat en
première lecture euh supprimer euh le
monopole des associations de
consommateurs représentatifes au niveau
national et agréé euh peut causer de
très gros problèmes euh notamment il
remettent en cause l'équilibre du projet
et je dois vous dire que lorsque nous
avons fait avec Alain faucogier euh la
soixantaine euh
d'auditions la le monopole des
associations de consommateurs a fait un
quasi
consensus c'est c'est un filtre qui peut
être salutaire pour justement empêcher
d'éventuels abus éviter
l'enlisement par exemple l'exemple
américain et l'action de groupe à la
française c'est se doter d'une action de
groupe favorable au consommateurs mais
respectant aussi les impératifs
économiques on veut êt un un pays de
consommateur mais aussi un pays de
producteur et c'est pour ça que on émet
un avis défavorable la commission des
Affaires éco aux amendements identiques
197 et 243 merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre même avis sur ces amendements
même avis je vous remercie s'il n'y a
pas de demande d'explication de vote je
vais mettre au voix ces deux amendements
identique le 197 rectifié bis présenté
par Monsieur Tandonnet et le 243
rectifié de madame Aichi qui est
pour 2 3
4 9 9
10 10 11 très bien qui est
contre alors 2 3
4 8 9 10
11 il n'est pas
adopté le 28 madame Bonnefoi au nom de
la commission des lois en tant que
rapporteur
oui par cet amendement la commission des
Lois vous propose de rétablir une
précision que nous avions adopté en
première lecture il s'agit d'éviter que
puissent prospérer des action de groupe
qui ne serait fondé sur aucun cas
concret en effet le droit de la
consommation connaît des situations dans
lesquelles le juge est conduit à se
prononcer de manière générale sur une
faute du professionnel par exemple en
matière de lutte contre les clauses
abusives cette fautete est susceptible
de causer des dommages au consommateurs
il ne faudrait pas toutefois que la
responsabilité du professionnel puisse
être engagée par l'association sans que
celle-ci présente au juges des exemples
concrets et individuels des dommages
ainsi causés aux intéressés il est il
est ainsi nécessaire de préciser que
l'association doit présenter des cas
individuels pour éviter que certaines
puissent se croire fondé à introduire de
telles actions de groupe sur la base de
seul préjudice
potentiel merci Madame vonnefoi l'avis
de la commission sur cet amendement de
la commission des lois précision très
utile à l'article
1er précision qui avait déjà été adopté
par le Sénat en première lecture mais
supprimé par l'Assemblée nationale
convient donc en effet que la décision
du juge portant sur la responsabilité du
professionnel soit rendu au vu des cas
individuels présenté par l'association
requérante la commission des affaires
économiques est donc favorable à cet
amendement merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre avis favorable je
vous remercie pas de demande
d'explication de vote je le mets au voix
deux avis favorables l'amendement 28
présenté au nom de la commission des
lois qui est
pour merci
contre abstention il est adopté le 92
monsieur tandonné vous le présentez
ou madame Dini
oui dans merci madame la Présidente dans
le choix qui a été fait pour la
constitution du groupe les mesures de
publicité du jugement ne peuvent être
mises en œuvre que lorsque tous les
recours ordinaires et le pouvoir en
cassation ont été épuisés
l'aboutissement de la procédure peut
donc être très long et surtout
déconnecté de l'acte déclencheur du
préjudice pour le consommateur cette
durée aura notamment pour conséquence
des pertes de preuves pour les
consommateurs lésés cet amendement a
donc pour objet de redonner un peu de
pouvoir au juge et de lui donner la
possibilité de déclencher la mise en
œuvre des mesures de publicité en
demandant une exécution provisoire si on
calcule le nombre d'années en cumulant
les recours un an tribunal de grande
instance 2 ans cours d'appel euh un an
cours de cassation ça fait 4 ans je
crois que les consommateurs seront déjà
découragés et je pense que cette mesure
d'exécution provisoire laissée à
l'arbitre au libre arbitre du juge est
très très
opportune merci chers collègues l'avis
de la commission sur l'amendement
92 cet amendement qui vise à ce que les
mesures de publicité prononcées par le
juge puissent faire l'objet d'une
exécution provisoire
euh pose deux problèmes euh sur la forme
tout d'abord euh il incompatible avec
l'alinéa 17 qui ne supprime cependant
pas et donc nous auri nous aurions une
contradiction dans le projet de loi s'il
était accepté deuxème chose sur le fond
il me paraît remettre en cause
l'équilibre de l'article 1er en étant
défavorable au professionnel il n'est
pas souhaitable de permettre la
publicité d'un jugement sur la
responsabilité d'un professionnel tant
que le jugement n'est pas devenu
définitive sous sous peine de porter euh
préjudice à l'image de ce
professionnel là encore on est sur
l'équilibre du projet de loi veillez à
ce que on défende à la fois les
consommateurs mais veillez à ce que
aussi on ne mette pas en cause les
professionnels avant que le jugement ne
soit définitivement pas rendu vous le
savez que dans les auditions avec alin
faucogier nombreux professionnels nous
ont dit qu'il préférait parfois payer
mais ne pas avoir de communication et
donc euh gardons l'équilibre pour éviter
à ce que comment l'équilibre du projet
de loi soit préservé on demande le
retrait de cette de cet amendement sinon
ça serait défavorable merci monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre indiquer à Monsieur
temp donné comme j'aurais pu le faire à
Madame Bonnefoi mais que comme la
plupart de de ces amendements en
l'occurrence là pour un avis défavorable
tout à l'heure pour un avis favorable
ont été examinés en première lecture et
que les explications du rapporteur sont
semblables à celles que nous avions fait
en première lecture je me contenterit
régulièrement d'un même avis à partir du
moment où mon explication serait très
largement redondante avec l'explication
du rapporteur donc même avis avis
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
vous êtes sollicité par pour un
retrait P pas le retirer je voulais
simplement rappeler que je soutiendrai
l'amendement
198 rectifier bis puisque c'est la la
Linéa 17 donc je suis cohérent avec mes
propositions voilà je pense que la
proposition reste équilibrée dans la
mesure où c'est laissé à la libre
appréciation du juge et que le juge
verra s'il est opportun ou non de
d'ordonner cette exécution provisoire ce
n'est pas une mesure
automatique collègueu je vais mettre au
voix l'amendement 92 présenté par
Monsieur tandonné deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour merci qui est
contre merci chers collègues abstention
il n'est pas adopté le 137 madame l mur
alors cet amendement vise à mieux
encadrer les mesures de publicité à la
charge du professionnel pour informer
les consommateurs susceptible
d'appartenir au groupe de la décision
rendue le juge pourra ainsi privilégier
au cas par cas une information
individuelle des consommateur concernés
ainsi que les mesures de publicité les
plus adaptées à la situation sans que
celle-ci s'avère dommageable pour
l'image de l'entreprise merci Madame l
mur l'avis de la commission sur le
137 je je pense que sur cet amendement
comme sur
d'autres il convient de ne pas trop
encadrer la la liberté du juge et c'est
à lui à déterminer les mesures de
publicité les plus adaptées par ailleurs
la liste qui est faite avec les quatre
proposition et pourrait pourrait être
limitative la Commission souhaite donc
en rester sur ce point au texte du
projet de loi avis défavorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
gouvernement même avis monsieur le
ministre même avis madame la Président
je vous remercie je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement présenté par Madame Lamur
deux avis défavoraable qui est
pour merci qui est
contre merci chers collègues abstention
il n'est pas adopté je suis saisie de
deux amendements faisant l'objet
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 198 rectifié
monsieur tant donné vous le
présenteer puisque c'était la suite de
ce qui vient d'être refusé donc je le
retire celui-là rez bien madamei vous
faites de même ou vous le
maintenez vous le retirez je vous
remercie trois amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur
cointin le 160
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le le ministre mes chers collègues en
fait c cet amendement t à clarifier la
possibilité de faire assurer par
mandataire judiciaire la liquidation des
préjudices en lieu et place du
professionnel ou de l'association et non
simplement au soutien de l'association
comme le propose la rédaction actuelle
du texte cela présenterait deux
avantages tout d'abord éviter une
asphyie des associations qui pour la
plupart n'ont pas des ressources
suffisante pour assurer la répartition
des préjudices et renforcer
l'impartialité de ce mandataire il faut
également prévoir dans ce projet de loi
que l'association puisse être chargée de
la liquidation des préjudices seulement
si elle est
d'accord car dans le cas contraire le
dispositif risque de paralyser les
associations de consommateurs en leur
faisant porter le poids de
l'indemnisation des victimes si les
associations de consommateur peuvent
initier l'action de groupe elles ne
peuvent assurer l'ensemble de son suivi
au risque d'être accaparé par une seule
action et être dans l'incapacité
d'emmener de nouvelles tel est le sens
de cet amendement de remédier à ces
difficultés merci Monsieur Quinta le 330
rectifié monsieur tondoné
oui c'est le 330 rectifié toujours dans
le même état d'esprit de ne pas retarder
les les procédures indéfiniment on on
sort du droit commun donc je rappelle
que l'action de groupe ce n'est qu'une
façon de saisir le tribunal en
regroupant des demandes tout le fond du
droit n'est pas changé et on ne voit pas
pourquoi à propos de l'action de groupe
on modifierait toute l'harmonie du Code
civil et du code de procédure civile qui
veut que les pourvois en cassation ne
soit pas
suspensif merci Monsieur toné Madame
ai
vous défendez merci
retir je vais demander donc l'avis de
notre rapporteur sur ces trois
amendements l'amendement de notre
collègue Christian cointa vise à
permettre au juge de désigner un
mandataire judiciaire au frais du
professionnel pour assurer la
liquidation des
préjudices la commission n'est pas
favorable à cesement pourquoi parce que
l'article L 4234
qui a déjà été adopté en terme identique
au Sénat ici dans cette assemblée à
l'Assemblée nationale prévoit déjà que
l'association peut s'adjoindre le
concours d'un/ers un professionnel du
droit un huissier un mandataire d'autres
professions membre d'une profession
judiciaire réglementé pour l'assister
dans toutes ces démarches inhérentes à
l'indemnisation des consommateurs y
compris à la liquidation donc c'est déjà
prévu par la loi le juge peut d'ailleurs
condamner le professionnel au paiement
d'une provision pour couvrir les faits
les frais auxquels s'expose
l'association en recourant à ce tiers
non seulement le projet de loi a prévu
ce tiers mais en même temps la
possibilité d'un paiement d'une
provision pour le rémunérer la
désignation d'un mandataire judiciaire
par le juge apparaît comme une
redondance et donc c'est un avis
défavorable nous proposons d'en rester
au texte de
loi on pourrait même dire retrait sinon
satisfait le 330 rectifié le 332 avis
des défavorable aux amendements 300
332 cet amendement vise à supprimer le
monopole des associations
représentatives et agréé là on a déjà
abordé très largement le le le projet et
le ce problème et donc même avis
c'està-dire avis défavorable je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre même avis
avec une précision pour Monsieur cointa
il me semble aussi que le texte actuel
couvre la préoccupation légitime qui est
la sienne c'est-à-dire que on se
retrouve pas dans une situation où faute
de moyens ou d'épaule en quelque sorte
une association de consommateurs serait
dans l'incapacité d'aller au terme d'une
procédure pourtant légitime justifiée et
et nous avons je crois tenu compte de la
préoccupation qui est la sienne dans
l'actuelle rédaction du texte donc je
ferai la même
recommandation suggérant le retrait de
de cet amendement merci Monsieur le
Ministre et les deux autres c'est le
même avis que la Commission monsieur le
ministre défavorable merci Monsieur
Quinta vous êtes sollicité à deux
reprises pour un retrait oui madame la
Présidente mais puisque monsieur le
ministre a reconnu que ma préoccupation
était légitime justifiée et qu'il
estimait qu'elle était satisfaite dans
ces conditions je retire l'amendement
merci chers collègue monsieur
tandonné 130 retiré merci madame vous
suivez retrait merci chers
collègues
le 29 madame Bonnefoi au nom de la
commission des
lois merci madame la Présidente
l'association percevra parfois
directement du professionnel les
dommages intérêts qu'elle devra reverser
au consommateur il est donc absolument
nécessaire de garantir la sécurité de
ces fonds et de les prémunir de toute
aléa de la gestion de l'association
elle-même des exemples récents
enseignent en effet que certaines
associations de consommateurs
connaissent une sit situation financière
fragile et peuvent faire l'objet d'une
liquidation judiciaire les députés
avaient prévu que l'association pourrait
à sa demande être autorisé par le juge à
s'attacher les services d'un
professionnel du droit par exemple un
mandataire judiciaire mais il ne s'agit
là que d'une possibilité offerte à
l'association notre assemblée avait donc
adopté un amendement qui ajoutait à
cette première possibilité l'obligation
pour le juge de fixer les conditions
dans lesquelles l'association percevrait
gérerai ou reverserai les fonds reçus
les députés ont supprimé cette mention
sans revenir à la rédaction initialement
adopté par le Sénat le présent
amendement propose de maintenir
toutefois une garantie sur la gestion
des fonds d'une part l'association
serait tenu de verser à un compte à la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation tous
les dommages et intérêts qui lui seraiit
remis et d'autre part les fonds ne
pourraient être retirés que pour être
versés aux consommateurs lésé ce
dispositif s'inspire de ceux applicables
en matière de liquidation judiciaire ou
de gestion de fonds par les notaires et
donc qui ont déjà fait leur preuve merci
Madame Bonnefoi l'avis de la
commission excellente amendement auquel
la Commission ne peut-être que favorable
indispensable de veiller à ce que ces
fonds ne soient pas employés à d'autres
fins ou éventuellement qu'il soit menacé
par la défaillance éventuelle de
l'association ou peut-être peut-être ça
peut c'est déjà arrivé une éventuelle
liquidation judiciaire avis favorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
oui madame la Présidente vis-à-vis de
cet amendement 29 de la commission des
lois de Madame Bonnefoi l'avis du
Gouvernement est
favorable il renforce les conditions
d'effectivité de l'indemnisation des
consommateurs al faisons en sorte que
les sommes qui sont prévu à des fin
d'indemnisation ne soit pas employé à
d'autres fins et et et en proposant que
elle puisse être en quelque sorte
sanctuarisée dans un compte de dépôt la
Caisse des dépôts et des consignations
raison pour laquelle l'avis du
Gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement de la commission des lois je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre il
n'y a pas de demande d'explication de
vote je vais mettre au voie l'amendement
29 présenté par la commission des lois
deux avis favorables qui est
pour merci contre abstention il est
adopté je suis saisit de H8 amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 93 monsieur tandonné
oui madame la Présidente donc le le 93
tend à supprimer euh la procédure
d'action de groupe simplifié introduite
à l'Assemblée nationale qui dénature la
procédure normale qui figure dans le
projet de loi je reste toujours dans euh
dans la même logique une action de
groupe qui permet de saisir le tribunal
mais qui ne déroge pas au droit commun
et un tribunal de grande instance non
spécialisé qui laisse aux juges et
notamment au juge de la mise en état
d'orienter la procédure avec tous les
outils dont il dispose dans ce ce code
de procédure civil donc elle met en
place un système qui mixte l'optout et
l'optin alors que le gouvernement a
toujours manifester sa volonté d'éviter
la première procédure pour ne pas tomber
dans les dérives du système américain au
début de la procédure simplifiée c'est
la procédure optout qui prévaut quand il
appartient au professionnel de
constituer le groupe via ces fichier
client en fin de procédure c'est celle
de l'optin car le consommateur doit
manifester son accord pour être
indamnisé elle installe également une
discrimination entre professionnels
suivant qu'ils pourront facilement
identifier les consommateurs ou ou
qu'ils auront un travail
d'identification des membres du groupe à
faire les premiers seront soumis à
l'action de groupe simplifié les seconds
à la procédure de droit commun et et
quel que soit le dommage subi par le
consommateur je pense que dans la
réalité cette ce distingo ne sera pas
aussi simple enfin elle est moins
sécurisante pour le droit de la défense
du professionnel dans la mesure où elle
ne prévoit pas qu'il puisse saisir le
juge s'il considère que certaines
demandes des consommateurs déclarées
dans le groupe sont illégitimes donc je
ne pense pas que ce soit une
simplification et je demande avec
d'autres collègues la suppression de de
cette procédure dite simplifiée merci
monsieur tendonné le 125 qui est
identique madame l mur
oui madame la Présidente cet amendement
tant à supprimer la procédure d'action
de groupe simplifié nous souhaitons en
effet que la procédure de droit commun
qui elle a fait l'objet d'un travail
depuis plusieurs années est auparavant
fait ses preuves merci vous présentez
les suivants je poursuis avec le 138
rectifié cette amendement précise
l'articulation entre l'action de groupe
de droit commun et l'action de groupe
simplifié car sous couverte
simplification la procédure d'action de
groupe simplifié dénature la procédure
de droit commun qui figure dans le
projet de loi alors cet amendement
rappelle qu'il appartient à
l'association de consommateurs
requérantes de demander l'ouverture
d'une procédure simplifiée par ailleurs
il est préciser que le juge se
prononcera comme dans la procédure
classique au regard des cas individuels
qui lui sont présentés et que le
professionnel reconnu responsable
indemnisera les seuls consommateurs
membres du
groupe et enfin le 139 rectifié donc
c'est un amendement qui permet aux
professionnels de faire valoir ses
droits de la défense s'il considère que
certaines demandes de consommateur pour
intégrer le groupe sont
illégitimes merci chers collègues
d'avoir présenté ces amendements en
continu le 169 monsieur
cointtin c'est un amendement madame
président monsieur le ministre tout
simple qui tend à laisser la possibilité
au juges de décider des mesures
d'information les plus approprié qu'elle
soit individuelle ou et collective pour
faire connaître au consommateurs leur
indemnisation en effet si l'information
individuelle est impérative elle
n'apparaît pas suffisante il faut donc
l'élargir merci chers collègues le
4 monsieur
tendonné oui euh cet amendement est une
proposition miroire à l'amendement
numéro 92 que j'ai précédemment défendu
sur la procédure d'action de groupe
classique cet amendement a donc pour
objet de redonner un peu de pouvoir au
juge j'ai lui donner la possibilité de
déclencher la mise en œuvre des mesures
de publicité et en demandant une
exécution provisoire tout à l'heure j'ai
vu que vous aviez hésité dans le compte
des voix j'espère que j'aurais convaincu
quelques collègues pour regagner notre
camp monsieur de étant donné vous
présentez en même temps le 331 rectifié
tout à l'heure c'était 12 11 c'était
presque
ça
madame Dini allez-y merci madame la
Présidente cet amendement vise à
supprimer le monopole des associations
représentatives et agréé nous insistons
pour engager une action de groupe cette
restriction limite en effet de manière
trop drastique l'accès de tous les
justiciables à la procédure d'action de
groupe alors que dans ce cadre la
référence à un groupe de consommateurs
est primordiale l'amendement introduit
la possibilité pour les consommateurs
d'agir directement en justice dès
dès lors qu'ils sont regroupés et en
nombre suffisant fixé à 50 et concerné
par le même préjudice l'avocat qu'ils
auront choisi pour ainsi conduire la
procédure nous sommes très entêtés merci
Madame DIN
madame défendu je vous remercie monsieur
le rapporteur je vais vous demander
votre avis sur ces
amendements les amendements 8 125 138
169 et 94 pte sur la même question
l'action de groupe
simplifié s'agissant des amendements de
suppression déjà déposés en première
lecture à savoir les amendements 93 et
125 la Commission ne peut être que
défavorable les députés ont réétabli la
rédaction qu'ils avaient introduite en
première lecture sans prendre en compte
ns remarques la le dispositif issu des
débats à l'Assemblée nationale vise à
accélérer
la procédure dans le cas où les
consommateurs sont
identifiés à l'initiative de la
Commission des affaires économiques nous
avons rétabli la version adoptée par le
Sénat en première lecture sous réserve
d'un ajustement permettant de répondre à
une critique formulée par le rapporteur
à l'Assemblée nationale la rédaction
adoptée par la commission permet de
clarifier les conditions dans lesquelles
cette proposition simplifiée peut être
engagée alors nous savons que parfois il
y a des organisations professionnelles
qui sont inquiètes sur cette action de
groupe simplifié la version adopté en
commission des affaires économiques
paraît plus encadré et plus précise
quant à ces conditions de
déclenchement je souhaite rassurer nos
collègues des groupes udi et UMP à ce
sujet la condamnation propos prononcée
par le juge dans le cadre de l'action de
groupe simplifié est bien entendu
susceptible de recours ce n'est pas une
condamnation sèche il y a possibilité de
recours la décision de choisir l'action
de groupe simplifié ou plutôt l'action
de groupe standard relève aussi du juge
en conséquence si le préjudice n'est pas
identique ou si les consommateurs lésés
ne sont pas réellement identifiés le
juge pourra faire droit des arguments du
professionnel et faire choix de la
procédure standard dans certains cas
chers collègues le professionnel
demandera demandera parce qu'il aura
intérêt à recour à recourir à une action
de groupe simplifiée il souhaitera que
l'action se termine rapidement par
ailleurs la publicité est individuelle
dans le cadre de l'action de groupe
simplifié ce qui est favorable au
professionnels en conséquence la
commission ne peut être que défavorable
aux amendements 93 et
125 en ce qui concerne les amendements
suivants la l'amendement
138 il me paraît contradictoire avec
l'amendement de suppression puisqu'il
maintient les conditions floues que le
juge peut utiliser dans la procédure
d'action de groupe simplifié à la
demande de l'association requérante
c'est donc un avis défavorable
l'amendement 139 qui dit que qui précise
que le juge peut-être saisi de en de
toute contestation par le professionnel
cet amendement est satisfait par le
projet de loi l'alinéa 27 mentionne en
effet la possibilité de recours et de
pourvoir en cassation c'est donc un avis
défavorable l'article 169 permet au
juges de décider des mesures de
publicité
collective et prévoit uniquement des
mesures de publicité individuelles parce
que ça pourrait être défavorable au
professionnel donc avis défavorable
amendement 94 nos collègues du groupe
EDI permet au juges dans le cadre de
l'action de groupe simplifié de
déclencher la mise en œuvre des mesures
de publicité même si la décision du juge
fait l'objet de recours on s'étonne un
petit peu de cet amendement qui est
contradictoire avec la volonté de nos
collègues du groupe EDI de protéger les
droits des professionnels ça pourrait se
retourner contre eux donc la décision de
la décision du juge ne pourra être
nuisible à la réputation du président
don il convient voilà avis défavorable
défavorable aussi au 331 333 qui sont
des amendements de conséquence merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre l' vie du gouvernement sur ces
amendements même avis je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre bien s'il n'y a pas
demande d'explication de vote je vais
mettre au voix le 93 qui a été présenté
par Monsieur tandoné et qui a eu deux
avis défavorables ah c'est le même que
le 125 présenté par Madame Lamur deux
avis défavorables qui est
pour merci qui est
contre merci abstention il n'est pas
adopté le 138 rectifié présenté par
Madame Lamur deux avis défavorables qui
est
pour merci
contre merci mes chers collègues
abstention il n'est pas
adopté le 139 rectifié présenté aussi
par Madame Lamur deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour merci
contre merci abstention il n'est pas
adopté le 94 présenté par Monsieur
tandoné deux avis défavorables qui est
pour merci qui est contre merci mes
chers collègues abstention il n'est pas
adopté le 331 rectifié et le 333 deux
avis défavorables qui est
pour merci qui est
contre merci et le 169 présenté par
Monsieur cointa deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour merci
contre merci abstention il n'est pas
adopté le 30 madame Bonnefois au nom de
la commission des lois
oui le présent amendement reprend dans
son esprit une disposition adopté par le
Sénat en première lecture mais supprimé
par les députés il s'agit de garantir au
justiciable la possibilité de contester
devant le juge en charge de l'action de
groupe le refus d'adhésion qui lui
aurait été opposé par l'association ou
le non respect par cette dernière du
mandat au fin d'indamnisation auquel
elle est tenue en effet toute la
procédure repose sur le le fait que
l'association dirige l'action de groupe
à la place des consommateurs lésés ceci
n'y participe qu'en rejoignant le groupe
et cette adhésion se traduit par un
mandat donné à l'association pour
s'occuper de leur indemnisation l'accès
au groupe est donc un point décisif or
en l'état du texte aucun recours n'est
ouvert pour les consommateurs contre le
refus de leur adhésion au groupe que
l'ASS que l'association leur opposerait
ou la non prise en compte de leur
demande d'indemnisation
il est évidemment nécessaire que les
consommateurs ainsi doublement laésés
disposent d'un recours et qu'ils
puissent se tourner vers le juge
compétent pour connaître de l'action de
groupe c'est ce que propose le présent
amendement en précisant que le recours
ouvert au nouvel article
l423-6 du code de la consommation
portera non seulement sur toutes les
difficultés rencontrées lors de la mise
en œuvre du jugement de responsabilité
cette mise en œuvre s'étendrait
j'insiste sur sur ce point de l'adhésion
au groupe à la liquidation des des
préjudices l'amendement modifie par
ailleurs en conséquence l'intitulé de la
section correspondante merci Madame
Bonnefois l'avis de la commission sur
l'amendement de la commission des lois
avis favorable merci Monsieur le
Ministre également un avis favorable à
l'amendement de Madame Bonnefois merci
s'il n'y a pas de demande d'explication
de vote je mets au voie cet amendement
présenté au nom de la commission des
lois deux avis favorables qui est
pour merci contre abstention il est
adopté le 84 le 95 madame diny monsieur
Bonnefoi monsieur monsieur pardon
monsieur tendonné oui madame la
Présidente l'amendement 95 euh la
question de la charge et du montant des
frais honoraires liés au recouvrement
dit amiaable ou forcé est essentiel pour
les consommateurs lésés il il importe en
effet de protéger les consommateurs en
évitant qu'ils puissent être débiteur de
sommes du au titre du recouvrement en
l'état actuel des textes le consommateur
demeure redevable des honoraires je
précise bien des honoraires d en matière
de recouvrement il importe que le
consommateur qui pourra être créancier
de sommees de faible montant ne supporte
aucun frais ou honoraire il convient
toutefois de mettre systématiquement à
la charge du professionnel la charge des
frais et recouvrement d'exécution c'est
pourquoi cet amendement propose
d'insérer dans le projet de loi une dis
une disposition prévoyant que
l'intégralité des frais et des droits
proportion de recouvrement ou
d'encaissement prévu à l'article L 1118
du code des procédures civiles
d'exécution pour l'application de la
procédure d'action de groupe est à la
charge du professionnel visé merci chers
collègues l'avis de la commission sur
cet
amendement cet amendement prévoit que
les frais de recouvrement et
d'encaissement sont à la charge du
professionnel condamné et c'est une
intention tout à fait
louable comme l'indique l'objet de ces
amendement l'article L 1416 du Code de
la Consommation permet déjà au juges de
mettre à la charge du professionnel
condamné l'intégralité des droits
proportionnels de recouvrement ou
d'encaissement mais l'amendement va plus
loin en prévoyant
l'automaticité de la mise à la charge du
professionnel et là nous préférons
laisser la liberté au juges voilà avis à
la fois tout en comprenant une bonne
partie de l'amendement est satisfait le
reste on le laisse à l'appréciation du
juge
avis desfavorable vous demandez un
retrait monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur vous
demandez un
retrait retrait ou défavorable retrait
ou défavorable merci Monsieur le
Ministre même avis même avis monsieur
tend donné vous le maintenez je le mets
au voix deux avis défavorables qui est
pour 11 12 13 12 13
pardon qui est
contre il est
adopté six amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune monsieur cointa
le
157 madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le projet
de loi dans sa version
actuelle précise que l'action de groupe
ne peut être mise en œuvre dans le
domaine de la concurrence tant que la
décision déterminant la responsabilité
du ou des professionnels est encore
susceptible de recours or nous l'avons
vu tout à l'heure à l'occasion de la
discussion d'un autre amendement ces
délais peuvent être très longs et même
dépasser les 4 ans évoqués par notre
collègue pour atteindre 5 6 voir 7 ans
or vous le savez très bien quand il y a
un
litige la notion de preuve est fond
fondamental il est donc essentiel de
sauvegarder ces preuves et donc c'est le
but de cet amendement qui tend à
instaurer une possibilité pour le juge
d'ordonner des mesures de conservation
des preuves qu'elles soi au main du
professionnel ou des consommateurs
s'agissant des manquements dans le
domaine de la concurrence et cela paraît
indispensable si on veut permettre aux
consommateurs de faire valoir
véritablement leurs droits merci
monsieurinta le 140 rectifié madame
Lamur alors propose de revenir à la
rédaction adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale en première lecture en effet
en matière de concurrence l'action de
groupe doit être subséquente elle ne
peut être introduite que sur le
fondement d'une décision devenue
définitive qui sanctionne une entreprise
pour pratique anticoncurrentielle or le
texte actuel permet d'engager une action
de groupe avant que la décision de
l'autorité compétente ne soit devenue
définitive cela pourrait donc avoir des
conséquences en terme d'image pour
l'entreprise alors même que les man
ement allégué par l'Autorité de la
concurrence ou la Commission européenne
ne serait pas confirmé c'est pourquoi
l'amendement propose de revenir à une
rédaction qui permet l'introduction
d'une action de groupe en matière de
concurrence sur le fondement d'une
décision définitive merci Madame l mur
le 37 monsieur mzard
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement 37 concerne les actions de
groupe dans le domaine de la concurrence
et il vise à permettre au juges
lorsqu'aucune décision n'a encore été
rendue par l'Autorité de la concurrence
de saisir lui-même cette
autorité pour que celle-ci rende un avis
lorsque la décision de l'Autorité de la
concurrence devient définitive le juge
pourra alors poursuivre la procédure
d'action de
groupe merci chers collègu le 334
rectifié Monsieur T donné oui madame la
Présidente oui je je soutiens
l'amendement formulé par Madame joanau
qui est dans la droite ligne de ce que
je défends depuis le début de cette
soirée c'est-à-dire rester dans le droit
commun éviter que nous les actions
soient soumises à des recours abusifs et
voilà le 335 madame
Aichi il est défendu
merci bien monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis attendez il y en a encore un je
pense oui le 141 madame la mur oui
madame la Présidente en en vertu du
principe d'indépendance de la justice
les décisions y compris définitives
d'une autorité administrative
indépendante telle l'Autorité de la
concurrence ou la Commission européenne
ne saurait lier totalement le juge
national et pour tenir compte la loi
française pour tenir compte du droit
européen précise et c'est l'objectif de
l'amendement le caractère réfragable de
la présomption selon laquelle les
manquements d'un professionnel relevé
par une autorité de concurrence sont
établis au fin d'une action de groupe
merci chers collègues l'avis de la
commission sur cette série d'amendements
les amendements 157 140 37 et 141 pent
sur la procédure d'action de groupe en
matière de concurrence pour ce qui
concerne l'amendement 157 de notre
collègue Christan
conta cet amendement vise à faire en
sorte que la durée de procédure en
permettant au juges d'ordonner la
conservation des preuve on pense que cet
amendement est en partie satisfait
puisque l'alinéa 15 de l'article 1er
prévoit cette possibilité pour toute
procédure d'action de groupe quel qu'en
soit de en matière la consommation ou en
matière de concurrence par ailleurs cet
amendement revient sur les dispositions
introduites au Sénat en première lecture
puis à l'Assemblée nationale en deuxè
lecture pour accélérer la procédure en
permettant l'engagement d'une action de
groupe simplifiée sans décision
définitive de l'autorité de la concur
urence modification que je rappelle qui
a été introduite par le Sénat et même le
prononcement de la responsabilité du
professionnel si la décision de
l'Autorité de la concurrence est devenue
définitive l'amendement de notre
collègue étant satisfait je lui demande
de lui de le retirer
euh l'amendement 140 de nos collègues
UMP est quelque peu contradictoire avec
l'amendement précédent puisqu'il cherche
à revenir sur les améliorations que j'ai
mentionné visant à accélérer la
procédure de
introduite par le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale la Commission ne peut donc y
être
favorable l'amendement 159 de notre
collègue Jean-Pierre plancadre reprend
compte à lui une disposition de la
proposition de loi déposée par lui-même
en proposant d'engager une action de
groupe en matière de concurrence sans
décision de l'Autorité de la concurrence
préalable la Commission ne peut-être
favorable à cet amendement déposé en
première lecture le contentieux des
pratiques anticoncurrentielles est un
contentieux très très technique qui
nécessite une expertise spécifique et
des moyens d'investigation
particulierers il donc préférable de
limiter l'action de groupe au manquement
constaté par une décision préalable de
l'autorité de la concurrence cette
solution permet également de soulager
l'association des consommateurs qui
n'aura pas à supporter le fardeau de la
preuve des pratiques
anticoncurrentielles donc je demande à
nos collègues de de retirer cet
amendement sinon ce serait défavorable
le dernier amendement du groupe MP
l'amendement 141 qui vise à revenir sur
la disposition du projet de loi selon
laquelle dans le cadre de l'action de
groupe en matière de concurrence les
manquements du professionnel sont
présumés établis de matière irréfragable
si uneautorité de la concurrence on a
jugé ainsi la Commission ne peut-être
favorable à cet amendement qui
allongerait la procédure qui allongerait
la procédure et qui pourrait conduire à
la remise en cause par un jure d'une par
un je d'une décision prise par une
autorité de la concurrence donc avis
défavorable sur les amendements 334 et
3315 335 excusez-moi sont des
amendements de
conséquences donc rejeté 37 monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai pas
entendu
défavorable présenté par Monsieur Mar
retrait est défavorable
merci Monsieur le
Ministre même avis sur que que le
rapporteur une remarque quand même sur
le le 37 de du président mard pour dire
qu'effectivement nous sommes arrivés à
un point d'équilibre incontestablement
entre la situation qui était celle
envisagée initialement modifié par le
Sénat vous proposez-vous d'aller encore
un petit peu plus loin le le point
d'équilibre il est lequel c'est qu'on
puisse effectivement quand une procédure
est ouverte auprès de l'Autorité de la
concurrence déclencher une action de
groupe avant que la décision soit
définitive mais quand il existe une
procédure ouverte auprès de l'Autorité
de la concurrence l'objectif c'est
d'éviter la déperdition des preuves nous
vons souhaiter dans les discussions nous
en arrêté là vous proposez d'aller
au-delà c'est aujourd'hui pas le choix
du gouvernement même s'il a suivi le
Parlement au-delà de ce qu'était la
version initiale de de son projet c'est
la raison pour laquelle je donnerai un
avis défavorable à cet amendement s'il
n'était pas retiré et sur le reste je
partage l'argumentation du du rapporteur
sur les autres
amendements bien je vais donc mettre au
voix sign monsieur quinttin vous voulez
vous exprimer je vous en prie
oui madame la Président Monsieur le
minist je voulais dire que j'ai relu
attentivement l'alinéa 15 de l'article
1er et donc je veux bien me m'aligner
sur les propos du rapporteur et donc je
retire l'amendement je vous remercie
chers collègues le 140 rectifié présenté
par Madame Lamur deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour merci qui est
contre merci chers collègues abstention
il n'est pas adopté le 37 de notre
collègue le président mard deux avis
défavorables vous retirez merci le 334
rectifié et le
335 tendonné ài deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour merci
contre merci chers collègues abstention
ils ne sont pas adoptés le 141 présenté
par Madame Lamur deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour 5 merci
contre merci abstention ils ne sont pas
adoptés je vais mettre au voix l'article
1er qui est pour voter l'article 1er un
vote sur article mes chers
collègues merci qui est
contre
abstention merci l'article est
adopté nous entamons l'article
2 l'amendement 96 monsieur donné vous le
présentez merci madame la Présidente
donc cet amendement a pour objet de
supprimer la désignation de tribunaux
spécialisés pour traiter des actions de
groupe je vous l'avais déjà présenté en
première lecture et le Sénat l'avait
adopté une large majorité
malheureusement une fois de plus les
députés n'ont pas entendu notre voix et
n'ont surtout pas entendu la voix des
territoires cette mesure est typiquement
une proposition qui peut et qui doit
faire exister notre Haute Assemblée face
à l'Assemblée nationale pour pourquoi
créer des tribunaux de grande instance
spécialisé pourquoi créer ces tribunaux
d'exception comme je le rappelais en
discussion générale je suis contre la
spécialisation de quelques tribunaux de
grande instance cela aurait plusieurs
conséquences négatives que je vous av
que je vais vous lister une
spécialisation inutile car les tous les
tribunaux de grande instance sont
capables de traiter des affaires de
droit de la consommation aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs c'est c'est leur quotidien on
ne crée pas ici un droit nouveau
l'éloignement de la justice alors qu'on
est sur une matière qui touche tous les
Français de tous les consommateurs
ordinaires souvent pour des procès
collectifs mais à viser local ou
régional une source de contencieux
nouvelle que ne manqueront pas
d'exploiter les juristes spécialisés
souvent au détriment du consommateur
avec des exceptions de proc de procédure
sur la compétence des contentieux locaux
à délocalisés sur des métropoles
régional et éloigner des affaires
traitées il faut bien avoir à l'esprit
que les actions de groupe ne sont pas
réserv à de grandes affaires qui ne
manqueront pas de défrayer la chronique
sur des opérateurs téléphoniques par
exemple mais il y aura aussi des
affaires locales selon le rapport de nos
collègues seulement h tribunaux seraient
spécialisés en action de groupe dont se
en métropole et uniquement un en
outreemre c'est une manière d'éloigner
encore la justice des citoyens et ce
n'est à mon avis pas tenable donc je
vous propose de supprimer ces TG
spécialisé de revenir au droit commun
pour l'action de groupe et puis si on
raisonne un peu plus loin on a dit qu'on
ferit des actions de groupe en matière
environnementale en matière de santé
donc encore de nouveaux tribunaux
spécialisés pour ces actions de groupe
en matière environnementale ou de santé
je pense que ce n'est pas tenable merci
chers collègues l'avis de la commission
sur l'amendement
96 c'est cet amendement reprend un
amendement déposé en première lecture et
adopté par le Sénat je dois le dire
contre l'avis du gouvernement et celui
de la commission il vise à supprimer la
désignation de tribunaux spécialisés
pour traiter
les actions de groupe les les problèmes
d'action de groupe je souhaite prendre
un peu de temps pour répondre à
l'amendement proposé tout tout d'abord
j'indique que cette disposition a été
réintroduite par le projet de loi
l'initiative conjointe des groupes
socialistes et UMP de l'Assemblée
nationale les députés du groupe UMP ont
notamment souligné que les organisations
professionnelles estimaient que le fait
de confier l'action de groupe à des
tribunaux spécialisés était un élément
d'équilibre du dispositif ensuite la
commission des affaires économiques est
favorable à la désignation de tribunaux
spécialisés pour plusieurs raisons la
première raison les actions de groupe
pourront se constituer pourront
constituer des contentieux de masse il
est donc indispensable de disposit de
disposer de juridiction dotées des
moyens et des compétences suffisants
pour traiter ce type de contentieux 2è
raison la suppression de la compétence
des tribunaux spécialisés conduirait à
s'en remettre aux règles de la
compétence du droit commun et ainsi à
confier à certains contentieux notamment
en matière de crédit à la consommation
au tribunaux d'instance ces derniers ne
sont pas entendus ne sont pas en mesure
de gérer ces contentieux susceptibles de
concerner plusieurs milliers de
consommateurs à l'inverse la désignation
de tribunaux spécialisés permettra leur
regroupement des actions de groupe à
l'harmonisation des décisions 3è raison
l'argument de la proximité n'a pas de
portée les consommateurs lésés ne
pourront pas en effet engager une action
de groupe par le biais d'une association
de défenseens des consommateurs
représentative au niveau national je
rappelle que le rapport 2010 de la
commission des lois de Richard Yun et
Laurent betille qui fait référence
aujourd'hui recommandait de faire
reléever les actions de groupe et la
compétence d'un nombre à un un nombre
limité de tribunaux de grande instance
spécial
CIT une proposition déjà à l'époque nos
collègues indiquaient dans un souci de
rationalisation des compétences et des
moyens il serait pertinent de réserver
la compétence en matière d'action de
groupe un nombre limité de tribunaux
spécialisés les greffes disposeraient
d'une taille suffisante pour traiter les
procédures les plus massives et les
juges développeraient une expertise
particulière en outre la question de la
proximité entre le justifiable le
justiciable et son juge de ne se pose
pas par une action conduite au nom des
justifibles par une association agréée
au niveau national la concentration des
contentieux dans quelques jurisdiction
est donc neutre pour le consommateur
enfin dernière chose je rappelle la
proposition de loi déposée le 5 avril
2013 par notre collègue Jean-Pierre
plancane et la plupart des membres du
groupe RDSE qui a été déposé sous forme
d'amendement à l'article 1 prévoit
également de réserver les contentieux
d'action de groupe à quelques TGI
spécialement désigné pour toutes ces
raisons la commission est donc
défavorable à cet
amendement merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre votre
avis éclairé par la proposition de loi
de Monsieur Plancade et du groupe RDSE
dans plus je plus je évidemment je
partage l'avis du du du rapporteur
quelques mot l'objectif que nous
recherchons c'est l'efficacité et la
réactivité ce n'est pas que les
tribunaux d'instance s'ils étaient
saisis est pas sauf qu'effectivement il
faut que dans le cadre des contentieux
de masse ils sont en capacité de pouvoir
porter euh euh euh des procédures d'une
taille taille je rappelle que la plupart
des actions de groupe auront lieu sur
des contentieux régionaux
interdépartementaux nationaux qu'il y a
300 tribunaux d'instance aujourd'hui
qu'il y a nous préférons réserver cela à
7 TGI en métropole 1 spécialisé outre
mer l'objectif c'est aussi d'harmoniser
les conditions des décisions et la
jurisprudence de faire en sorte des éité
les doubles saisines dans 300 tribunaux
d'instance qui provoqueraiit là beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de complexité et et
une faciliterait pas le déroulement des
procédures nous voulons éviter aussi
l'éparpillement c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons privilégié comme la
plupart des propositions qui ont été
faites historiquement sur l'action de
groupe cette modalité des TGI
spécialisés nous voulons là que nous
puissions avoir une mise en œuvre de la
justice qui soit la plus réactive la
plus efficace la plus harmonieuse
en capacité de faire en sorte de
produire une jurisprudence qui soit
utile c'est la raison pour laquelle je
je donnerai un avis aussi défavorable à
cet amendement de du sénateur t donné
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
mard merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
écouté avec intérêt monsieur le ministre
se référé à une proposition de loi
déposée par un membre du groupe RDSE ce
qui est rare et cher donc je vous en
remercie ceci étant il peut il peut
arriver que sur un élément d'une
proposition de loi on puisse se rendre
compte à la lecture d'un certain nombre
d'éléments et des interventions des uns
et des autres que une solution
différente serait préférable en ce qui
me concerne en tout cas j'ai toujours
été très réticent sur les juridiction
spécialisées on est en train au fil des
mois de multiplier les juridictions
spécialisées ce n'est pas une bonne
chose parce que là ce sont les actions
de groupe on sait que il y a on a
récemment eu il me semble un procureur
financier on a une multiplication de
systèmes spéciaux qui sont contraires à
une bonne administration de la justice
et qui en outre et qui en outre ont une
conséquence évidente au et très négative
en ce qui concerne l'aménagement du
territoire monsieur le ministre nous
avons déjà des déserts médicaux au train
où on va vous êtes en train de créer
quand je dis vous c'est le gouvernement
mais le précédent on avait autant à son
crédit ou à son débit plutôt on est en
train de créer des déserts juridiques
nous avons besoin monsieur le ministre
dans tous nos territoires de matière
grise inelligence de professionnel et
vous êtes en train de faire en sorte
qu'on vide ces territoires et ici vous
êtes dans une assemblée qui qui encore
pour quelques temps représent les
collectivités locales et les
territoires et
oui enfin ça vous savez c'est pas les
urbains qui vont nous expliquer comment
ça marche dans nos territoires en Clavé
enfin pas encore en tout cas il y a il y
a il y a manifestement avec des
dispositions de cette nature là des
Herms parce que c'est une volonté de
nombre
d'administration j'allais dire de de la
technocratie de multiplier ces systèmes
là avec des aberrations vous nous dites
il y en aura
se en métropole et puis il y en aura une
juridiction pour le territoire d'utrem
alors quand on habite à la Réunion
faudra aller plaider à la Guadeloupe ou
l'inverse mais qu'est-ce que c'est que
ça franchement il manque que cliperton
installé là à
clipererton sinon je peux vous
conseiller croser Saint- Paul Amsterdam
au g Hélène hein au moins ça mettra un
peu d'animation mais franchement
franchement je crois que c'est c'est une
très B chose nos juridictions les les
magistrats ils sont formés normalement
de la même manière par l'École nationale
de la magistrature ils sont et ils
doivent être capabl qu'ils soi juges
d'instance hein à maobug à oriac à mand
ou à Bordeaux de travailler sur ce type
de litige et bien évidemment la première
juridiction qui sera saisie et bien
pourra traiter de l'ensemble je crois
vraiment que là il faut dire stop par
rapport à la multiplication de ces
juridictions merci Monsieur mesard
monsieur le
ministre juste pour renvoyer à ce qui ce
qui se passerait euh déjà en vertu des
règles de litispendance il y aura
regroupement il peut y avoir double
triple quadruple qu'un tuple saisine je
je vous mais dans devant la réalité de
ces quintuples cisunes sur des
contentieux nationaux on se retrouve
dans une situation très compliquée en
matière de déclenchement et de poursuite
des procédures d'action de groupe
pourquoi est-ce que on on on on choisit
les les tribunaux spécialisés pas parce
qu'on considère à un moment qu'il faut
avoir une politique de défiance à
l'égard des territoires ce serait
absurde ce serait d'autant plus absurde
qu'il me semble et c'est là que monsieur
le Président je vous demande de faire
justice pour le coup à la politique de
ce gouvern en matière de justice c'est
que les moyens sont mis là où ils
avaient été retirés auparavant et que
les choix qui sont fait aujourd'hui en
matière de de carte judiciaire sont pas
exactement les mêmes que ceux qui
étaient fait auparavant première chose
et deuxièmement là nous parlons des
actions de groupe moi je je me permets
de dire que le consommateur d'un produit
d'un service de téléphonie à orillac à
trappe à clichis sousbois à Paris à nîes
ou à saint-renant ce qu'il veut c'est
être indemnisé rapidement de manière
effective efficace et pour cela
aujourd'hui au regard effectivement des
moyens qui sont parfois inégaux d'un
certain nombre de tribunaux en
l'occurrence entre ce que serait ces
tribunaux de grande instance spécialisé
les tribunaux d'instance nous n'aurons
pas les mêmes résultats la même
réactivité la même efficacité ce qui
n'est en rien la condamnation de du
travail remarquable des juges d'instance
mais la réalité aujourd'hui des moyens
et en attendant que ces moyens soient
rétablis moi je vous le dis si nous
voulons que l'action de groupe ne
déçoive pas qu'il a pas un effet
déceptif lié à la mise en œuvre de cette
action de groupe de surcroix il faut
privilégier ces jurisprudence c'est
juridiction spécialisé et en
l'occurrence c'est le choix du
gouvernement que de vous proposer C TGI
là nous prenons sinon à mes yeux au
regard aujourd'hui de l'organisation de
notre carte
judiciaire des risques que la justice
soit beaucoup moins efficace qu'elle ne
pourrait l'être grâce au
TGI merci merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur tondonet
oui moi je je veux répondre à deux
arguments celui de de dire que le
tribunal de grande instance ordinaire
n'aurait pas les moyens le propre d'une
action de groupe c'est justement de
regrouper toutes les victimes et de
n'engager qu'une seule procédure devant
le Tribunal il n'y aura qu'un seul
représentant et c'est l'association et
l'avocat représentant l'association
l'avocat qui don la présence est
obligatoire qui représentera cette
association donc il n'y a pas besoin de
de moyens complémentaires pour diriger
cette action de groupe même si vous avez
30000 victimes vous aurez une seule mise
au rôle une seule action un seul avocat
et une seule association qui assurera la
défense de de ces victimes et dire alors
c'est un argument nouveau qu'on avait
pas en première lecture avancée c'est de
de de faire peur en disant mais il y
aura les 300 tribunaux d'instance qui
pourraient être saisi parce que on est
dans dans l'action du contrat de
consommation faut il faut pas oublier
que le tribunal de grande instance est
saisi obligatoirement dès que l'intérêt
du litige dépasse 10000 ou 15000 € voilà
donc c'est le tribunal de grande
instance qui sera normalement saisi et
si jamais le tribunal d'instance devait
être saisi il faut pas oublier que c'est
justement le spécialiste du droit de la
consommation et que en attendant les
lois des des des lois sur la protection
des consommateurs comme celle
d'aujourd'hui les tribunaux d'instance
ont été les précurseurs pour défendre
les consommateurs et c'est vraiment
d'être un gras aujourd'hui de leur
sortir de cette compétence et je je
répète encore que le droit commun
s'applique devant tous les tribunaux
qu'il n'y a rien de dérogatoire à ce
droit commun et que donc les tribunaux
ordinaires sont bien compétents pour
pour examiner ces demandes merci chers
collègue monsieur
Mazard oui madame le Président Monsieur
le Ministre pour rejoindre donc les
propos qui ont été ceux donc de de mes
prédécesseurs euh je comprends pas
tellement la l'argumentation du du
gouvernement puisque
euh aujourd'hui à la limite c'est pas
une opposition entre le ti le tribunal
d'instance et le tribunal de grande
instance si vous voulez euh que que que
cette matière ressort de la compétence
du tribunal de grande instance il y a
pas de difficulté ce que nous contestons
c'est le fait que on demande à seulement
8 TGI de s'occuper de l'ensemble de ce
conten alors que tous les TGI de France
et d'outrem donc seraiit en capacité
pour nous de gérer ce ce type de
contentieux euh moi je ferai crédit pour
le coup à ce gouvernement qui a remaillé
le territoire donc en redéployant des
moyens qui avaient été enlevés par le
précédent gouvernement je crois que
justement c'est un signe fort de vouloir
donc redonner du contenu donc dans tous
les départements en matière de justice
ce serait dommage aujourd'hui donc
finalement de faire marche arrière sur
un type de contentieux qui à mon avis a
vocation à à être traité par par par
tous les tribunaux et puis un dernier
mot on a bien vu justement à l'occasion
du redéploiement euh des moyens donc sur
l'ensemble du territoire avec la
réouverture de certains TGI comme Tul ou
saintgudin ça a été cité à l'instant ou
la création de chambres délocalisé comme
ce sera le cas dans mon département à
mot on a bien vu qu'à ce moment-là donc
les études démontraient que c'était dans
les petites juridictions pour le coup
que les délais d'évacuation étaient
meilleur donc l'argument qui est de dire
ben les grands tribunaux auront plus de
moyens il est pas du tout recevable
puisqueaujourd'hui i les petits TGI donc
dans les départements 10 ruraux
démontrent que les dossiers sortent très
bien et avec des délais tout à fait
raisonnables et puis un dernier mot sur
ce sujet euh
aujourd'hui malgré le fait qu'il va y
avoir plusieurs consommateurs qui vont
actionner ils vont le faire par le biais
d'une association donc on va avoir un
dossier ce sera le dossier de
l'association contre tel industriel ou
tel professionnel et ce sera pas pour le
coup une multiplicité de de de de
nouveaux dossiers donc voilà donc donc
je crois qu'aujourd'hui sur le plan
purement technique au plan de la
pratique judiciaire il n'y a aucun
argument qui peut s'opposer à ce que
tous les tribunaux connaissent de ce
type de contentieux le premier tribunal
saisi connaîtra de tout le contentieux
qui pourra s'élever en la matière sur le
territoire national merci Monsieur
Mazard monsieur le
ministre juste dire que s'il n'y a pas
compétences pour les TGI spécialisé ce
qui qui veut donc dire compétenence des
Tribunaux d'Instances et du juge unique
sans obligation d'assistance par avocat
je rappelle sans obligation hein tel que
c'est aujourd'hui ça veut dire que tous
les dossiers Crédit Logement seraient
donc traités dans ces conditions dans
les tribunaux d'instance je vous le dis
à nos yeux aujourd'hui nous nous
cherchons à mettre en œuvre une
procédure tout à fait nouvelle nous
prendrions potentiellement un certain
nombre de risques à la mise en œuvre tel
quel sur la mise en œuvre d'action de
groupe dans le domaine du crédit du
logement avec le juge unique dans les
tribunaux d'instance c'est des garanties
en moins sans doute pour le le
aujourd'hui la les procédures et son
efficacité son effectivité raison pour
laquelle nous sommes favorables au
maintien de ces tribunaux de grande
instance spécialisé merci monsieur le
ministre je pense que le Sénat est
éclairé j'ai été saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe udi UC sur
l'amendement 96 je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
que l'avis du Gouvernement est
défavorable monsieur le ministre vous
voulez vous exprimer faites-le avant le
vote avant que le le scrutin soit ouvert
si on peut tomber d'accord sur une
position de repli qui
dirait plutôt que les TGI spécialisés
tous les TGI moi je veux bien qu'on
atterrisse sur cette proposition
là Monsieur tendonné est-ce que vous
acceptez de rectifier l'amendement oui
oui madame la Présidente si l'amendement
gouvernemental soutient que tous les TGI
de France et d'autres mèes sont
compétents je j'accepte cet amendement
bien entendu c'est c'est c'est le but
que je
poursuis merci cher
collèg56 ça sera l'amendement ça sera
l'amendement
356 très bien l'amendement de le
sous-amendement du gouvernement a été
donc accepté par l'auteur de
l'amendement nous sommes d'accord très
bien merci et donc la suppression de la
formule de scrutin public on est entendu
merci
merci nous arrivons à deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion
commune monsieur
Doliger voter 356 il faut
voter pard oui vous avez complètement
raison je vais mettre au voix le 356
ainsi rectifié qui est
pour présent
oui merci contre abstention il est
adopté merci je me contente de l'accord
de Monsieur tandonné ça n'est pas
suffisant donc deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 248
n'est pas défendu il tombe le 301 n'est
pas défendu il
tombe une série d'amendements également
le 249 n'est pas défendu il tombe le 302
rectifié également le 250 aussi j'arrive
au 317 madame l mur oui madame la
Présidente merci l'objectif de cet
amendement est d'encadrer l'application
des actions de groupe dans le temps en
matière de consommation afin que
celle-ci ne puisse s'exercer qu'en cas
de manquement à des obligations légales
ou contractuelles survenues au plusut
tôt 1 an avant l'entrée en vigueur des
articles 1 et 2 de la présente loi
l'absence de ces dispositions en effet
affecterait gravement la sécurité et la
stabilité juridique essentielle à la
compétitivité des entreprises et à
l'attractivité de la France merci Madame
Lamur le 63 rectifié monsieur
mard
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la majorité
des amendements déposés sur cet article
2 en 2è lecture concerne l'entrée en
vigueur et l'application dans le temps
du dispositif d'action de groupe
institué par le projet de loi notre
amendement vise lui aussi à limiter la
rétroactivité de l'action de groupe en
ne permettant l'introduction d'une
action de groupe que pour des
manquements qui sont intervenus au
plusutôt 2 ans avant l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi dans la mesure où la
rétroactivité du dispositif ne serait
pas encadré à l'heure actuelle dans le
projet de loi cette précision nous
semble utile et même nécessaire pour
garantir la sécurité juridique de
l'action de groupe et je dis ça sous
réserve des explications qui pourront
nous être apporté par Monsieur le
Ministre merci Monsieur mza Madame Lamur
le 316 et oui madame la Présidente il
s'agit à travers cet amendement
d'encadrer dans le temps l'application
des actions de groupe en matière de
consommation en effet il paraît utile de
limiter dans le temps l'application des
actions de groupe au manquement passés
en matière de consommation sans modifier
les possibilités d'action individuelles
là encore l'absence de disposition en la
matière affecterait gravement la
sécurité et la stabilité juridique
essentielle à la compétitivité des
entreprises et à l'attractivité de la
France merci Madame Lamur euh celui-là
ou c'est bon monsieur le rapporteur je
vais vous demander l'avis sur le 317 le
63 rectifié et le l'identique qui est le
116 le
316 uniquement sur ceuxa les autres
tombent absolument on a six amendements
sur le même sujet 250 249 302 63 316 et
3 37 c'est ça madame vous demande juste
un avis sur le 317 le 63 et le 316 les
autres sont tombés monsieur le
rapporteur alors sur le
317 c'est un amendement qui correspond
au même esprit prévoyant que toute
action de groupe ne pas être envisagé
engagé que pour des manquements survenus
au plutôt 1 an avant l'entrée en vigueur
de la
loi la commission n'est pas favorable à
ces amendements l'article 1er est créé
par les nouveaux manquements ou de
nouvelles peines il institue juste une
nouvelle procédure pour sanctionner des
manquements qui sont déjà sanctionnables
aujourd'hui par le biais d'action
individuelle autrement dit si nous
votions ces amendements il s'agirait
d'une forme d'amnistie et je rappelle
enfin que si l'action de groupe
s'appliquera à des manquements
intérieurs à la publication de la loi
elle ne s'appliquera pas aux manquements
qui ne sont pas prescrit autrement dit
les manquements qui ont eu lieu depuis 5
ans parce qu'il y aura prescription
alors avis défavorable à ces amendements
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre oui ces amendement propose
d'intrire ce qu'on appelle une clause de
grand-père qui des facto existe par les
règles de prescription
de non grand-père et de grand-mère si
vous voulez Mad procassia bon peu
importe une clause de grands-parents en
quelque
sorte en tout cas de 1 ou 2 ans en
l'occurrence elle existe déjà à travers
les règles de prescription euh et qui
est de qui sont de de de 5 ans nous
avons voulu dans le choisir là encore
l'équilibre et faire une distinction
entre ce qui relevait du champ de la
concurrence avec des effets
macro-économiques qui pouvaient être
potentiellement très importants et très
déstabilisateurs pour notre économie
s'il n'y avait pas de clause de
grand-père et en même temps refuser d'en
mettre une pour les les les préjudices
liés au litigge de consommation pourquoi
parce que là euh nous n'avons pas les
mêmes effets macro-économiques par
contre je vous l'indique si jamais C
cette clause était mise en œuvre il y
aurait des affaires qui pourraient être
jugées rapidement permettre une
indemnisation importante d'un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes consommateurs
qui les amèneraient donc à perdre le
bénéfice de l'indemnisation du préjudice
qu'ils ont subi et qui ne manqueraient
pas de nourrir leur ressentiment à
l'égard de la représentation nationale
je vous le dis au regard d'un certain
nombre de de de cas qu'on peut
aujourd'hui intuiter par rapport à des
affaires relativement récentes raison
pour laquelle le choix du gouvernement
c'est l'équilibre une clause de
grandpère dans dans le champ de la
concurrence pas de gros clause de
grand-père dans le champ de la
consommation dans le champ de la
concurrence en raison des effets
macro-économiques potentiellement très
déstabilisateur mais je le dis il n'y a
pas de problème de rétroactivité
puisqu'il s'agit d'une le procédurale
nouvelle et qu'elle n'entre pas dans le
champ de de de de la rétroactivité qui
est interdite c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'avis du Gouvernement sera
défavorable sauf évidemment retrait de
votre part de de de de ces amendements à
partir de l'argumentation qui a été
celle du rapporteur et de moi-même merci
Monsieur le Ministre madame l mur vous
avez été sollicité pour un retrait pour
le 317 que décidez-vous
il est maintenu madame la Présidente je
vous le maintenz très bien je le mets au
voie deux avis défavorables qui est
pour merci qui est
contre merci mes chers collègues
abstention il n'est pas adopté le 63
rectifié présenté par Monsieur mard et
le 316 présenté par Madame Lamur qui
sont identiques deux avis favorable qui
est
pour monsieur mzard vous êtes d'accord
avec
vous-même merci
contre merci abstention ils ne sont pas
adoptés je mets au voix l'article 2 un
vote sur article mes chers collègues qui
est pour ah madame l mur
oui merci madame la Présidente très
rapidement monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues les amendements du
groupe UMP sur l'action de groupe sur
cette cet article 2 mais également sur
l'article 1er sont dans l'ensemble
identiques à ceux que nous avions déposé
en première lecture nous avons toutefois
choisi de ne pas déposer certains
d'entre eux je pense notamment à celui
qui est préconisé de limiter l'action de
groupe à un groupe significatif et
identifiable de consommateur monsieur le
rapporteur nous avait alors répondu que
cette précision n'était justement pas
assez précise juridiquement c'est un
argument que nous avons bien pris en
compte mais pour tous les autres
amendements le choix de déposer de
nouveau c'est imposé à nous parce que
nous considérons que les réponses et du
rapporteur et du ministre étaient
insuffisantes en ce qui concerne
l'encadrement des mesures de publicité à
la charge du professionnel de même sur
la procédure d'action de groupe
simplifié nous pensons que les mesures
de publicité ne protègent pas
suffisamment la réputation des
entreprises et nous pensons que l'action
de groupe simplifié ne présente aucune
garantie notamment en matière de droit
de la défense et que cette procédure
deviendra la procédure de droit commun
alors je voudrais répondre à la critique
qui nous a été faite selon laquelle nous
voudrions une action de groupe à minima
il y a là une contradiction comment en
effet des amendement essentiellement
rédactionnel peuvent-ils casser l'action
de groupe pourquoi penser que
l'encadrement des mesures de publicité à
la charge du professionnel est une
exigence trop intrusive pour les juges
il est encore du ressort du législateur
de s'assurer que la loi est bien
appliqué selon sa volonté enfin notre
seule véritable exigence de fond est la
supr de l'action de groupe simplifié
mais ne nous répondez pas qu'en
supprimant l'action de groupe simplifié
on dénature le texte c'est justement
l'action de groupe simplifié qui
dénature le projet de loi initial je
répète cette procédure a été intégrée
par amendement en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale aussi je regrette
que nous ne puissions pas nous entendre
sur cette procédure d'action de groupe
la non suppression de l'action de groupe
simplifié aura été pour nous
déterminante l'avancée sur les droits
des consommateurs que représente
l'action de groupe ne saurait mé
connaître les droits de la défense c'est
pourquoi je vous confirme que nous
sommes défavorables à cet article 2
comme nous l'étions à l'article 1er
merci Madame Lamur y a-t-il d'autres
demandes de parole avant le vote de
l'article je n'en vois pas je vais
mettre l'article au voix qui est pour
voter l'article
2 merci qui est
contre merci abstention l'article 2 est
adopté après l' article 2 un amendement
247 madame
ai madame le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement demande l'établissement d'un
rapport sur les modalités d'extension de
l'action de groupe en effet c'est
l'inttroduction de l'action de groupe en
droit français qui constitue une avancée
attendue depuis longtemps ouvre la voie
à un droit nouveau et permet une
protection indispensable pour le citoyen
consommateur elle reste imparfaite en
l'état l'action de groupe circonscrite à
un seul type de préjudice matériel subi
au seul champ de la consommation crée
une rupture d'égalité des citoyens de
lois nous sommes tous tout à fait pardon
conscient monsieur le ministre que le
présent texte est précisément dessiné
destiné pardon au seul champ de la
consommation et que les ministres de
l'environnement et de la santé se sont
engagés à mettre en œuvre des procédures
d'action de groupe dans ces domaines
toutefois cette réponse nous semble
inadaptée en l'état actuel le dispositif
écarte les citoyens victimes des trop
nombreux scandales sanitaires et
environnementaux que sont laamante le
médiator les prothèses PIP en l'état
donc actuel de la loi les victimes
seront réduites à se faire rembourser
des boîtes de médicaments ou des
prothèses en silicone sans percevoir la
moindre compensation pour le préjudice
en matière de santé se trouve également
exclu les PME ou les petits porteurs
ayant subi un préjudice qui ne relève
pas du droit de la consommation mais du
droit des sociétés ou du droit boursier
il est donc souétable de se donner les
moyens d'apporter une réponse claire et
adaptée à ces situations de préjudice de
masse en demandant un rapport sur les
modalités de l'élargissement de l'action
de groupe le gouvernement pourrait
témoigner sa volonté à s'engager dans
cette voie mais surtout son son
engagement à ne pas compartimenter le
mécanisme de l'action de groupe qui en
affaiblit la portée à terme il pourra en
résulter la présentation par la garde
dut d'un projet de loi sur une action de
groupe globale qui concernerait tout
type de préjudice merci merci chers
collègues l'avis de la
commission l'avis de la commission c'est
que cet amendement est satisfait par
l'article 5 de l'article
2 l'alinéa 2 oui adopté euh
oui l'alinéa 5 de l'article 2 adopté
dans les mêmes termes par l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat qui prévoit la
remise au Parlement d'un rapport 30 mois
après la promulgation de la loi faisant
le bilan de la mise en œuvre de l'action
de groupe proposant des des adaptations
et envisageant des évolutions possibles
tel que l'extension au domaine de la
santé et de l'environnement puisqu'il
est satisfait nous demandons le
retrait merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre même avis oui même
avis l'article 2 prévoit déjà un rapport
à 30 mois il y a pour courant 2014 des
avancées qui seront réalisées dans le
domaine de la santé et de l'action de
groupe santé il est nécessaire de
disposer d'un recul suffisant pour être
en capacité de verser un rapport utile
au travail et de l'exécutif et du
législateur c'est la raison pour
laquelle euh nous sommes favorables à
l'équilibre actuel du texte et nous vous
demandons où le retrait de ce texte
sinon avis défavorable merci Monsieur le
Ministre madame
Achi vous le
maintenez j'ai pas entendu euh est-ce
que vous le maintenez oui je vous le
maintenz très bien je vais le mettre au
voix l'amendement 2 monsieur
Cornu mon je crois qu'on on a quand même
une responsabilité sur les rapports
parce que maintenant on ne sort pas à
chaque fois qu'il y a un texte on se on
se retrouve à la fin du texte avec de 3
4 5 rapports après si on veut vraiment
faire travailler tous les fonctionnaires
et les occuper avec des rapports alors
effectivement il faut continuer mais je
crois qu'on a une responsabilité
collective de faire attention à ne pas
charger la barque et donc d'essayer de
limiter les rapports donc moi je ne vote
pass cet amendement merci Monsieur Cornu
je le mets au voix deux avis
défavorables qui est
pour merci
contre merci mes chers collègues
abstention l'amendement n'est pas
adopté voilà les sénateurs ont donc
terminé hier l'examen de l'article 4 du
texte qui appartient au chapitre 2 de ce
projet de loi sur la consommation
chapitre qui porte sur une meilleure
information du consommateur il reste
encore 230 amendement examiné sur ce
projet de loi sur la consommation qui je
vous le rappelle est examiné ici en 2e
lecture au Sénat et parmi les points qui
reste à aborder bien il y a encore la
question de la traçabilité de la viande
la question du fait maison ou encore le
surendettement et la libéralisation de
l'optique vous le voyez des points et
bien extrêmement variés pour ce texte
qui aborde la consommation d'un point de
vue extrêmement général voilà prochain
rendez-vous de l'actualité parlementaire
et bien cet après-midi à 16h30 pour 24h
ca présenté par Delphine Gérard très
bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires le club des municipales
c'est le rendez-vous dédié aux élections
municipales autour de Gill